last night we had sean parnell on the
show he is a republican running in i
believe it's pa 17 is that
do you know that that's a dis that's a
district if you say so tim i think so
all right all right so it's like north
of pittsburgh and uh he's down
he's still officially canada i don't
think they've they've certified the the
election results yet but he is on track
to lose
and he's filing a lawsuit uh challenging
the constitutionality
of mainland voting in pennsylvania
because their constitution already has
an absentee ballot provision
and the republicans were not not this is
these are my words not
not his in my in terms of my opinion he
said that the republicans were trying to
pass this law and started the
constitutional amendment process and
then stopped
and then passed the law anyway which
means sounds like they knew what they
were doing
was unconstitutional so apparently
pennsylvania governor announced that he
certified the results
and and uh seems like it was done
hastily in an effort to try and bypass
any litigation or whatever
my understanding is that uh pa didn't
certify in 2016 until december so like
they waited for a while now they've
they've like rushed it through i didn't
even realize it happened but a judge
today said
stop the certification process it's not
official and
now you've got the democrats being like
yeah well we still picked our electors
you can't stop us and it's just going
crazy
i don't know exactly what's gonna happen
but trump is also filing an appeal
trying to get
republicans in pennsylvania to
choose their own electors he's certainly
not giving up they had this hearing
where they were talking about voter
fraud and stuff which
that that that hearing stuff they're
doing makes me feel like
they're uh not taking it seriously
because it wasn't as at a hotel but uh
you know what
you know i don't want to get into too
much we also got some stuff about covet
maryland's going crazy they're launching
compliance units that are going to go
around like
tracking down people who are celebrating
thanksgiving open up your door and let
us
in they're going to take like uh gopros
on swivels and like you know race up to
the window and be like there's people
that
now they're going to look for cars
outside if there's too many and this is
this is for real
they're all my cousins they all live
here yeah everybody lives here get out
of here we're car collectors
that's right well it's getting crazy so
anyway uh you know
in sick so is chairs empty but uh gone
hello everybody good to see you
i'm glad to be back lydia yeah i am
chilling chilling in a big way
jack murphy live here on tim cast i love
it
yeah so uh a lot of people are saying
like tim where are your videos you know
what man uh
it's chill day holidays are really
really hard to work through
because no one else is working so it's
like you're trying to
like you're dragging your car by
yourself with a toe rope
you know it's it's hard to do something
when no one else is doing anything it's
like yeah but
your your audience has to acknowledge
that they feel an absence
but that absence is created through your
persistence and consistent hard work
you're on the grind like nobody else
putting out more
political commentary and news reporting
than virtually anybody out there is that
right i think so i was talking to a
podcasting network and they said i do
more political commentary
than anyone else anywhere now there's
probably
some people you know they're talking
about in terms of the top podcast
doesn't count when we're talking to ian
as political commentator oh of course of
course yeah yeah
so we do i do i do three hours and 45
minutes yeah every day
uh except for saturdays and sundays
that's an hour and 45. so some days when
we go over
to uh way over 10 o'clock it's like it's
like four four hours and 20 minutes
there are some days where i've done like
seven hours yeah for real like when we
did uh
when we had vosh and alex jones that was
that was like five hours six hours of
political commentary in a single day
right like that's crazy right right but
podcast commentary and content stuff
and you're doing this consistently over
time and delivering high quality people
are looking for you they're waiting for
you and when they don't get that
notification bell which you should hit
me up smash that like subscribe like
subscribe hit that notification bell
you're gone you're gone but guys tim's
got to take a break what you've been
doing what are you going to do
well it's it's it's so i'm actually
thinking of doing only one
20 something minute segment um for in
the morning on timecast news
and then my 4pm segment on my main
channel so that we can start the vlog
and do
non-political commentary content which
means i'd still have three hours of
political commentary every day no
non-political commentary evergreen
commentary fun stuff educational stuff
i mean not silly nonsense we're gonna
we're gonna build a giant
airbag and launch ramp and like
snowboard and stuff and
fun maybe maybe break the record for the
longest uh
grind rail ever ever grind you know done
there you go just just
something else you know i think uh yeah
it's just it's too much in one direction
it's too much political commentary how
much do you think you're
45 minutes your experience of having
your content getting sort of
consumed by political commentary is that
like marrying the rest of the world you
think it's everybody yeah
like everyone's doing political
commentary yeah yeah because uh
uh i think this was a strategy of the
democrats
they wanted everything to be political
because they needed non-voters to vote
they needed
they needed regular people who don't
care to vote how do you get
some you know 23 year old dude who's
playing video games all day to vote for
joe biden
you scream in their face and take
everything away from them and scream in
their face again and finally
fine god joe biden there you go leave me
alone right exactly
we talked about that a few weeks ago
about the democrats beating their people
over the head gaslighting torturing them
you know yeah basically threatening them
and the only thing they could do is just
vote to make it stop but part of that
comes from critical race theory and
activists that have like produced all
these people
these young kids who've taken over
corporations they're taught that
politics is personal it's all personal
and you have to make it personal you
have to even get in people's personal
spaces
make people uncomfortable and it's
consumed everything and then you take
away
you can't go to the football games you
can't go to the basketball games you
can't go to
any can't do anything only show in town
is politics
i think we may have crossed the breaking
point yeah like the hard breaking point
in this country
so i've talked you know i frequently
said you know we're sitting on the
precipice or maybe we've gone over it
i think we hit the ground i think we
went over the precipice a while ago when
we hit the ground with this election
you know there was a hearing the uh
today
yeah it's a wyndham in gettysburg and
you had a bunch of republicans and they
were witness listening to
testimony and man you had some legit
people there there was one one guy who
was a former intelligence officer who
worked psychological operations
who was testifying you know trump trump
called in but yet a lot of people
speaking
that that whole thing it's weird
it kind of freaks me out well can we can
we just back up for a second set the
stage there like
how do you have a hearing in a hotel
ballroom because it's not official
it makes me wonder like was anybody like
under oath or sworn
things or anything because it was just
yeah it had the feeling of a hearing but
it was really just a sophisticated
or maybe presentation i think what
they're trying to do i don't know i'm
asking
i think they're trying to there's like a
large angry maga beast
snarling it's like you know what you
know desert is a good example it's
it's it's uh like trying to calm down
the hulk like you know
don't worry hulk like you know you're in
the here's the here's the real hearing
come sit down and
you've got all these angry maga people
that are you know ready to smash
and so they're like we're going to do a
hearing and then they show up and
everyone's clapping and cheering and
it's like bro they're putting you in the
kitty room
and and blowing smoke up your ass now
some people out there put you know
well-known commentators on the right
they saw they saw that
that hearing and and it really changed
the way that they felt about
you know was there some sort of systemic
fraud at play at least in this state
there
and in terms of they don't believe it
anymore they believe it even more they
know that they believe that that it's
time for the democrats to refute the
allegations that they're serious enough
yeah they're credible enough yeah that
the people
of the allegations are credible enough
that that it demands a refutation
actually proving them to be false
that's why i'm saying we we we went off
the precipice a while ago and
we smacked the ground of the precipice
of what that's what i didn't understand
like the point of no return where
this country's divide was getting worse
and worse every day oh yeah
and jumping off the cliff was the point
where you can't turn back and then
hitting the ground is the point where
that
it's it's just done and now we're
staring at each other and
and people are counting heads none of
this in my opinion
uh matters we we know there's evidence
the media is saying there's not evidence
it's just an absolute lie
did you see that poll and i don't know
who conducted it so i'm not sure exactly
if it's 100 accurate but it seemed to
suggest
that they pulled biden voters after the
election and asked them had they were
they aware of hunter biden were they
aware
operation warp speed were they aware of
our energy independence under trump et
cetera et cetera and they weren't
and they said if they were they would
have voted for trump in a small
a small enough person a large enough
percentage but it was a small percentage
it was like typically around four to
five percent of the people said wow i
wouldn't have voted for biden if that
was the case and that's a huge swing for
trump it would have been sufficient
the media was doing everything in their
power to help joe biden
social media was doing everything in its
power to help joe biden
joe biden did not campaign and got 11
million more votes than barack obama
no way doesn't make any sense tim so
listen
i you come to me and you say dude but
people really hate donald trump i say oh
you betcha
but to beat barack obama without
campaigning
now perhaps you can say i mean hold on
just barack obama
i went out to vote for barack obama man
i was motivated
i waited in line i was proud to vote for
barack obama
i really was in 2008 i certainly was
come to regret it obviously yeah me too
but it was a moment in time it felt
right and like
there was no similar energy around joe
biden but maybe maybe this does prove
once and for all
hopefully not that hate is more
motivating than
than love or hope i'm not i'm not
entirely convinced
that widespread voter fraud is the is
what cost trump the election
i think i think we got to see evidence i
think what we have right now is
the smoke alarm is going off and smoke
is billing out the windows it's time for
the firefighters to go in there because
we think there's smoke
so you know for me i've seen enough the
investigations need to happen but
here's the point i'm saying where we
smack the ground yeah it's not going to
matter
especially when you have these hearings
now it's silly that they're happening
and you're like a windham or whatever
that's like
what are they doing you know they're
gonna do it in a couple other states i
guess
but some of these people man these are
these are
when i was listening to the
certification process for michigan some
of the people who called in
for public like to say do not certify
these were like former government
officials
yeah these were like uh you know like
relatively high ranked individuals in
various organizations and government
who have said rattling off all the
evidence calling out the law and they
said
f you f you man that one guy his name
was like aaron van
langeveld was one of the most feckless
and pathetic people i've ever ever had
to listen to
it's like you had a guy say like under
this section of the law it says
for for any reason necessary you can
call in adjournment like you can adjourn
the meeting and he goes
well i can't just make something up and
they're like
if you can't certify which is defined as
determining if something is true then
you can call for an adjournment until
they
sort out these these errors and he goes
well i just don't think that's in the
law anywhere sorry
and it was like he said it like 10 times
and i'm like dude you like it was so
obvious
that he was doing everything in his
power to guarantee this for joe biden
and and you had people like one guy
called in and rattled off a ton of crazy
evidence affidavits
you know sworn statements statistics
statistical anomalies
the things people had seen and uh the
unbalanced books for instance
70 whatever percent you know signatures
didn't match how many votes were cast
people who had said that they didn't
request absentee ballots but absentee
belts got sent to him anyway things like
that
indeed and this guy goes well you know i
don't know i guess you know whatever i
have no choice you know sorry
it's like you wouldn't exist unless you
had a choice like why would you even be
in that position you're there for a
reason to certify
or you can say i can't certify this
because the books are unbalanced one
one explanation for that is that he was
trying to advance the ball for biden
another explanation is that he was so
soft and scared
and incapable of making a principal
decision or making a hard decision or
taking action or anything like that i
don't think he was trying to advance it
for biden
no i think he's just scared he's a
terrified weak
little man this is the crisis the crisis
of weak men
yeah so when you hear that the wayne
county board of canvassers
some some guy goes on the zoom call and
says your kids probably go to this
school
and they immediately certify yeah
exactly so this guy
who is you know should not be in a
leadership position
he sees that he immediately says i have
to i have to i have no choice
and the reason he was saying that was
because he doesn't want republicans
getting mad at him but guess what
time and time again i'll tell you this
it's because republicans
will do nothing conservatives
nothing you mean in terms of like
fighting aggressively or
so antifa breaks the rules and gets away
with it yep 100
and the only like the only thing
comparable is probably the proud boys
and they typically are defensive they'll
show up and do a rally and then
antivirus attacks them and then they'll
fight back
but antifa is aggressive and they get
away with it it's overt terrorism
it's low tier terror it's not like
they're showing up with you know with
like you know aks and mowing down
you know kids or anything like that but
they're saying just picking off trump
supporters one by one on the streets of
portland
it has happened but the here's the thing
that you want you want to stay under the
radar you can't do high-profile
attacks like that like reinhold did so
what you do is
you just put on a mask and you club
people and then eventually people get
scared but cancel culture was the first
start
that was them saying comply or else we
will destroy you
and i'll tell you one of the biggest
problems i would say it would seem
that there's probably like i don't know
four or five percent of trump supporters
who are cowards
they're smart enough to know they need
to vote for him but they were too
terrified of what the left would do to
him to speak out and evangelize on his
behalf
so i said this about all these
celebrities who i know support trump but
refuse to speak up because they're like
oh lose my job
and i'm like you will wake up one day
with a joe biden presidency
and everything you hold dear being
stripped away and you'll say i wish i
had spoken up sooner because i had a lot
of influence and i could have used it
bro you are preaching to the choir on
this one my friend i have arrows in my
back from being out front
people have been free riding on my
willingness to go out there personally
and stump for trump
and advocate for him and say he's the
best choice that we had as far back as
2016. obviously
democrats deplorable he'll transition
everything they destroyed your career
they did
tried hurting your family they did they
hurt me they got me
fired and doxed and slandered and all
kinds of horrible things
and yet you know i persist and and i
look around at people who i know
feel the same way but don't speak up and
i'm like i'm out here i'm out here i'm a
lightning rod
i'll say this from now on if anyone ever
whenever i'm ever gonna bring up
not being scared and speaking up i'm
just gonna say be like jack murphy
because people always say tim you don't
have a family you know what it's like
it's like all right well then ask jack
because you you stuck your neck out you
were speaking out they came for your
family and you pushed twice as hard
after the fact
indeed you weaponized it i had to you
know
this energy came at me it was negative
energy it was this terrorism info terror
like character assassination etc and
they came after me and i jiu-jitsu
around
into something positive there was you
know it was an opportunity i mean when
you
see the world in terms of opportunity
and energy and you see it all coming at
you and you have a chance to turn around
into something good
you know i seized on it and plus
living well is the best revenge there's
no question about that
so so think about this guy this this
michigan uh state uh
uh on the state board of canvassers yeah
who
was no matter what was said to him
citing the law setting evidence he said
well you know i have no choice
one guy said if that's the case then why
are you here not a rubber stamp for the
governor who use
we can hand the files to him you don't
you exist for a reason in fact they had
the opportunity to vote
like they literally counted the vote
three to zero with one abstaining
it's like so you could have literally
voted no but this guy wouldn't and it's
really simple why i've been saying this
for quite some time
so are you you're familiar with sargon
of akkad right indeed i saw that whole
thing just happened recently oh
go ahead no i don't what happened
something happened maybe i haven't met
well anyway he's got a uh a new podcast
called the lotus eaters by the way so
shout out sargon
but i use him as a really good example
because he is like the most
mild-mannered offensive guy you know
that like the the social media age
has wrought and here's here's the
example
if twitter started banning a bunch of
people
and a bunch of crazy stuff happened do
you think sargon of akkad is going to
lead a group of
liberalists men you know with fedoras
and beards down to
twitter hq with pitchforks and torches
to smash and destroy everything
no of course not no he's sitting in his
nice little fancy room with his british
accent you know giving arguments
if they started going after the left do
you think the left would show up with
pitchforks torches and bricks
no but i do have account the answer is
yes i'm sorry sorry yes they've done it
i
literally have done it i'm sorry i had a
counter point in my head to be an
argumentative jerk about it
laura loomer she did show up down to
twitter
yes not exactly pitchfork but is anybody
scared of her she
she handcuffed her her hand to the door
yeah and and she got pressed for it
it's probably i mean honestly she she
is one of the best activists or the best
the wright has
yeah and you don't gotta agree with her
i think she said ridiculously bombastic
things and offensive things and you
don't gotta agree the point i'm making
is
she always knows how to dominate
headlines yeah and she does it in such a
way that's like nobody's getting hurt
handcuffing yourself to twitter's door
like that's just regular old civil
disobedience and it worked yeah
so here's what happens this guy aaron
you know he's
uh you know a sad scared little man
who you know he shouldn't be in a
leadership position if you can't handle
the
the the heat you know it's the sword of
damocles you want to sit in that chair
the sword sits above you how do you even
get to that spot is it just something
out of appointment has he voted in like
something
the problem is we don't have leaders
anymore we have very very few i should
say
and so what happens is here's a guy
sitting there and he sees what happens
when the democrat state board when the
two democrats said we are going
to certify did republicans announce
where their children lived
and threaten them so where are you the
answer is no
no i know where are you going with this
critique that
the left is violent terroristic
like antifa types i mean these aren't
even these are like regular democrats
in the community saying your kids go to
school here yeah no it's a perfectly
normal thing on the left to say all
kinds of stuff like that
and they know that when they say that
antifa is the
is is the cudgel who will show up and
act and they'll say it's it's what's it
called stochastic terrorism yeah
they know that they can say don't your
kids go to this school
and then they'll say now i can only no
now all i have to do is sit back and
wait for antifa to show up
because they'll do it i don't got to
tell them so this guy's terrified he's
absolutely terrified the other guy
abstained he didn't even say no
these people are spineless so you have
aggressive angry violent deceitful
leftists
and you have scared conservatives saying
just please leave me alone
right and i agree with you the
ineffective
wimpy guys like that or leaders of any
kind shouldn't be there we need stronger
leaders we need masculine energy we need
all kinds of
new force however i just want to make
sure i understand this
the left of those played dirty are you
suggesting the right should play strong
or play dirty too they got to be smarter
they got to be
they got to be smarter so look you know
i play i've grown up playing strategy
games
and what the left is doing is aggro
their strategy is hard
hard and fast strike hit them low hit
them fast
get it done the republicans got to play
control better
they have to understand you know exactly
what they're going to do
they're going to make threats they're
going to come for your family
you need to know their move before they
do it and so that like you know bruce
lee
move like water when they come at you
spin around flip it on them
turn the energy back on them you did yes
that's exactly what you did yes they
came
at you and they made you 10 times
stronger 100 times stronger yes
that was a mistake and counting that's
what more people on the right need to be
doing
so it's not about playing dirty it's
about
you know i'm reminded of this episode of
frasier you ever watch frasier i sure
did i watched cheers and then fraser all
right
so uh there's an episode where i guess
frasier is having a bad day
and he has his normal table at the
coffee shop and he's got his coffee sit
down
he goes up to grab some creamer or
something and a guy sits in his chair
and he gets angry and he says sir this
is my seat and the guy tells him to f
off so so frazier just says i'm having a
bad damn not having it picks the guy up
and throws him
so eventually this guy sues him knowing
he's like a radio host he had money and
uh you know frasier can't do anything
about it so eventually they end up
meeting back at the coffee coffee shop
and then niles gets in his face and then
you know
you know starts pressuring him and
insulting him and then the guy says back
off man and pokes his chest
and then niles goes whoa and falls over
and slams onto the floor
and then he goes counter suit counter
suit and then the guy backs off
and says okay i give up the point so the
joke was
and he was like i didn't do anything no
he's like well you we all watched you
touch him
you know that's it you're gonna get sued
niles got the suit shut down by
playing the same game that the guy was
playing got it so i'm not saying
like definitely not republicans should
not be going out doing antifa stuff and
people shouldn't be doing that either
right but what do you do if you know the
d.a will cut these people loose
boom like that because they got they got
elected in the first place
well they have a whole infrastructure
you and i talked about this many times
and i take
i take extra special pleasure now in
documenting the legal defense fund folks
oh yeah when they're out there in the
protest copying down the officer's badge
numbers and giving out bail numbers and
helping people get out of jail
as you said not being there to observe
both parties but actually there as an
advocate for antifa
they have a whole network that
encourages them they get out of jail
they're not prosecuted it's a it's a
whole system we don't have that system
because we adhere
to the system of the rule of law and we
expect that if you destroy property or
federal property you're gonna go away to
federal prison
so what do you do if you're playing
monopoly yeah and the person across the
table
every so often you see him swipe a
hundred from the bank and you go dude i
saw you do that and you'd be like
what are you talking about no i'm just
talking about i'm allowed i'm the banker
eventually do you stop playing i mean
you're putting me in a tough spot
because i'm the kind of guy that would
either confront or just completely
ignore the table well you just you know
i like to
pick my moments of aggression like that
and sometimes it's just not worth it but
but the alternative here of just like
getting up and walking away from the
board game
that's easy i can do that i can be like
dude i want to hang out with you anymore
i'm not going to play this game anymore
i'm out and i just leave we we do not
have that luxury
no that's uh it it
that exists in the real world and that's
the scary that's the
hitting the ground moment that's what
i'm saying yeah we're at a point where
yeah we've seen the evidence there is so
much evidence of first irregularity
because fraud we got to figure out who
did it and
is it definitive so uh following matt
brainard of the voter integrity fund
he recently put out a database like just
like screenshots of excel
of people all using the same commercial
address as their residential address
some of them even post offices
yeah so so the response to that was that
they were they were using their mailing
address as their residential address so
that could be
a mistake right but some of these
addresses were just like
one of them i think was uh uh like like
a shopping mall or something like okay
and and the difference is they say
apartment on them
so if you're gonna if you're gonna use
the same address and then call it
apartment number
to make it seem like it's a real
residence that that's fraud that's
evidence of fraud outright
one of the things that he pointed out
that struck me was that in i think
wisconsin i believe
there is a particular clause that says
if you are indefinitely confined
you can get an absentee ballot and not
have to show id
and it's like some excellent 169 000
people and definitely definitely can
find
right in previous years it had been some
fro tiny
production yeah of that in 2018 i think
it was like 16 000. and and he
specifically noted that corona
was not an indefinite confinement so it
that's
one area where you don't need to use a
id so of course that's a perfect vector
for so that is the best evidence so far
of fraud in my opinion was that people
put
bunk addresses if you take an address
for a you know dairy queen and then put
apartment number on it
yeah we know what you're doing that's
that's fraudulent some of them are even
the post office
well but the argument there is that well
you have like a po box yeah so their
mailing address was
incorrectly listed as their residential
address i see see that's nice i'm not
saying it's definitively true that's
what happened but
you can explain it away right you can't
explain away someone listing
a a shopping mall as their as their
residence right like
and and and was like a thousand of them
all with the same address going down
with unit number apartment number you
know just like different ways to qualify
like
this is actually it's not a residence so
there clearly
is evidence of fraud now it's not
definitive proof it could be very simple
at this one shopping mall
somebody has a mailbox or something like
that and then again confuse their
mailing address
someone pointed out that you actually
like in some instances you can put your
mailing address as your residence on
some form or something and maybe got
mixed up
but you can explain it but the point is
we have all of this evidence and going
back to the hitting the ground moment
the fact that republicans held a hearing
at a windom means
the split has happened right why aren't
they having that meeting in an official
government building
right because they're now operating
parallel to the government
don't say it tim why not beginning the
beginning
of the shadow uh well cnn ran a segment
where this deranged guy said trump's
going to form a shadow government
i wouldn't call it a shadow government
but i wouldn't be surprised if trump
says
if you support me and you believe me to
be your president
i will be leading a movement um he could
yeah and it could operate within the
confines of the law but it could have
powerful
and massive impacts across the country
people have accused obama of running a
shadow government
shadow presidency this whole time living
but merely a mile away from the white
house
yeah colorama in washington dc near
besos
bezos who bought a museum dude he bought
a
museum and turned it into his private
residence
in downtown washington if we have to
have hearings at wyndham hotels
because we we're not we can't have them
in actual legal buildings with
legitimate legal proceedings
then it shows you that people are no
longer
confident in one unified system the
government exists based on one thing
confidence
that people think in their minds the
machine exists and the machine will
churn along
you start to realize then when you see a
judge and pa
issue ridiculous rulings or you start to
hear the state cannabis guy in michigan
repeatedly just say i can't do it even
though he got the law in front of him
saying he literally can
and it's like dude you're lying why are
you like you literally can the guy read
you the law
three times desperately trying to say
i can't shows you the laws become
meaningless
for the past year we have seen antifa
get away with uh
smashing things up and destroying things
and burning things black lives matter
sin felonious assault assault with a
deadly weapon
murder and so let's not sugarcoat it
well but some the
the people the most violent people did
get arrested and get you know charged
in that regard but we had what thousands
of people across the country who were
arrested and released
immediately many hundreds in chicago
hundreds in new york and dallas fort
worth
who had their charges dropped
misdemeanor charges
so then what's the point of the law if
these people can go out and smash things
and get away with it what's the point of
the law
if anti-fuck can literally organize
terroristic events
on twitter with no repercussion and
they've been doing it nonstop for a year
at a certain point republicans got to
say the law doesn't actually mean
anything because it doesn't get enforced
then they're going to show up to a
wyndham hotel to have their hearing on
voter fraud
because they're rallying among
themselves saying we
know this is true and it doesn't matter
if the official building
or the democrats think it is or isn't we
we so
at a certain point there's not
necessarily a shadow government
but i've been saying this for quite some
time with the censorship they are
pushing to create parallel economies
by stripping people away of their
financial institutions and
communications so now we have parallel
social media growing faster than ever
parlor over 10 million users now
you have like i mentioned hearing in a
hotel like an official proceeding it
looked like it was
like it was a senate hearing but they
were doing it in a hotel which is crazy
and you have cnn worried about trump
forming a shadow government
but there are people who say
legitimately trump won and we know it
and they're not
you you had uh rhodes of the oath
keepers say
that he believes trump supporters half
the country
will not regard anything out of obama's
i'm sorry anything out of biden's mouth
as legitimate so it's it's like the
fracture has happened
yeah we smack the ground boom it's done
yeah these parallel
uh circumstances economies information
markets networks associations these are
all happening this is all part of the
trend of decentralization and street
strategic disconnection instead of us
all being in the same thing with no
borders and no boundaries and totally
connected to everyone everywhere at all
times
we are going to start retreating some of
it's deliberate in an offensive way from
the other side to silence us or separate
us from the mainstream or whatever the
case
but some of it is coming from our side
too some of it is just a natural
phenomenon at this point where
you want to erect a barrier you want to
have a wall between yourself and the
people you care about and the people
that you don't know and that you don't
have the same level of care for
who people who might have it out for you
and eventually we're going to have not
just parallel
financial systems or economies or labor
markets but
decentralized and just it's just sort of
all a big mix but they're all connected
in their own unique ways
and it really is the future of work it's
the future of communication of finance
where people are going to come together
and build their own networks
where they can live work and play and
this is you know this is not this sort
of a longer term
vision here yeah but that's that's going
to lead to widespread violence
if we're talking about trump supporters
well i was talking about a little bit
different thing than you're talking
about but
i hear what you're saying if if
republicans and trump supporters right
now
are have no longer have confidence in
the elections
in the government in the system and
they're going to start doing their own
thing
and i they probably will so like one of
the things i said a month or two ago
when someone asked me like what do you
think it's going to look like if we do
see some kind of civil war i said
it's going to be a bunch of right-wing
dudes in the middle of nowhere just
basically saying
we no longer care about what the law is
like if they pass a law on gun control
saying
you're turning your guns they're gonna
be like yeah who are you talking about
forget it
yeah and we saw we saw seeds of that
starting in the spring in january in the
winter
in january in richmond in virginia when
the governor and
the legislature there were looking to
pass very restrictive gun laws
many counties said that they wouldn't
have forced the laws and they were
joining together and resistance and
there was just a huge protest where a
bunch of armed dudes were walking around
i'm not sure if it was virginia or dc
i think it was dc couldn't have been dc
no that that's that was the point i'm
pretty sure oh really
yeah yeah yeah ford fischer was covering
it i think it was dc i could be wrong
but it was basically like these guys are
violating
in large numbers gun control laws we'll
see what happens
oh i didn't hear about that i'm gonna
have to look that up if there's a gang
of armed dudes walking through the
streets of dc
all felony possession boom i can't
believe that they didn't get scooped it
may have been virginia
yeah that would it may have been in more
sense like yeah an apartment
reported it yeah was reporting it but it
was a while ago it was like a week or
two ago
okay so i don't know just see if you can
google it it's going to be opt out think
it's already happening think about if
you are a democrat in montgomery county
maryland and you don't believe
that we should have restrictive
immigration and your county
says basically hey if you show up here
we'll give you services we'll take care
of you you get a driver's license
and if we arrest you even for a violent
crime
we won't engage with the federal
immigration authorities whatever so
they started this a long time people
have been ignoring the government
i think since and even before it was
incepted so that was one thing i want to
do i want to step back a second and just
be like look
remember 2016 all those all those
democrats were like
you should engage electoral college and
change the vote and whatever
and they're saying that you know it's
all there's a video of a bunch of
celebrities saying
you will be a hero electoral college if
you vote your conscience and do not
elect donald trump
right amazing what are they saying today
well they're saying the exact opposite
and if you suggest that
you're a terrorist and a rebel and
whatever but my point in bringing that
up
is how much of these feelings that we're
having
the sense of disintegration or i won't
respect him not my president and all
that or
like ignoring federal laws how much of
that is really new
that's that's what i i want to know
sanctuary cities have been a thing for a
long time civil disobedience has been
saying for a long time ignoring federal
guidelines and laws and regulations
staying for a long time state
republicans having hearings in wyndham
hotels
like d this is pretty good good good
example
decriminalization and legalization of
cannabis on the state level
even though it's federally prohibited
that's a great example of states
ignoring the federal government well
disregarding the law and saying screw
you we're going to do what we want
that's different though
why it's just i think it's the same
thing when a state says
we want we are a sovereign state you
know and we've decided there was a big
wave of states declaring sovereignty
you know i think it was like 12 years
ago or so that's
the states always have their own laws
and under you know and they can there's
a lot of laws that don't you know work
with federal laws it's different when
you have two overarching
cultures with 70 plus million on each
side
for the most part not every single
person who voted for biden or
against trump or for trump are you know
super politically active
there's probably a lot of people who are
just like democrat and you know
republican well let me just say
thematically then
it's the same in that disregarding the
authority of the federal government
deciding to do what you think is right
and not accepting it as legitimate
what's coming from washington d.c that's
on theme those roads have already been
traveled
will we see more of that probably i
don't i don't i don't think so
i think sanctuary laws are like a legal
challenge
where the people in the state like they
agree and they vote for something
and then the feds challenge them and
there's a lawsuit and then the feds
ultimately back back off
right and then that that's that's it you
don't get cooperation
it's different when you have in the
state
in the same areas two different factions
of people
completely at odds with each other doing
different things as though there's a
different government or different system
for
uh um so would you take the monopoly
board and just
flip it over and fling everything
everywhere and say we gotta start over
and get a whole new game or are you
gonna get up and walk away are you gonna
punch the guy in the face what are you
gonna do tim
man uh walk away
but it's it's that therein lies the
serious problem of what is what does it
mean to walk away in this analogy
i got a house out in the middle of
nowhere and i'm doing my own thing
and uh uh they the lockdowns are getting
uh bro we're we're well beyond the point
of these these dystopian novels
maryland announced they're launching
compliance units
that are going to patrol thanksgiving
looking for cars that
could indicate someone's having family
over compliance
units i mean that's as absurd as i saw a
joke
about like banning turkeys over 12
pounds or something like that yeah yeah
it was news them like no 10-pound
turkeys
no that was a joke that was a joke i'm
pretty sure it was a joke
oh i don't know somebody brought it up
but did you see the thing they said
about no loud music
no what does that have to do with covet
well not to be the party pooper on that
one but
loud music does induce people to speak
more loudly and enunciate more clearly
all right which is which is why which
which
you're not allowed to play music at
restaurants and i was like what what is
that about no yeah
the volume has to be low so that you
don't yell so you don't spit all over
everybody
i kind of which actually is one of the
ones that
only ones that really make any sense to
me yeah yeah but they also said no
alcohol
that's fun yeah everyone will follow
that definitely and but you know i'm
seeing some pushback man
i'm seeing some pushback i've seen in my
local jurisdictions
parents getting together and and
agreeing that their kids should be
playing little league that their kids
should be playing baseball they should
be doing crew they should be playing
tennis
that they should have group practices
and they should try to find events like
people are people are tired they
understand understanding the damage
that's being done to them
and their kids and their development and
their social development that's kind of
interesting to me because i looked up
the word feckless because i didn't
really know
and the root word of feckless is
irresponsibility
and i think that parents who are looking
for ways to get their kids out of
lockdown
sadness are being responsible right
people are looking for ways to make
positive change or being responsible
for people like this guy who didn't
certify are irresponsible
i have the tweet from ford fischer he
says today boogaloo boy mike dunn led
militia activists on an armed march
in laps around the capital in richmond
virginia where it's illegal to carry
guns at protests
and it's illegal to carry 20 plus
20-plus round mags
police stood back and did not intervene
as the group defied both laws
wow this is uh a large group of people
and they're twenty first carrying lots
of weapons yeah and violation of the law
and it's richmond virginia it's not dc
right he says he's got another follow-up
he says police monitored the area many
carrying long rifles themselves but did
not intervene
as the boogaloo boys marched by them as
well as signs reading firearms
prohibited beyond this point
other than pleasantries like good
morning police didn't really speak to
them in fact in the beginning of his
video you can see a sign that says
notice
and there's a picture of a handgun in
with a red circle the line through it
so there have been protests before
there's been
widespread civil disobedience before but
has that been combined with widespread
factional violence
and 70 plus million people believe in
the election
you know or i should say to be fair
based on the polling we've seen it's
around
80 percent of trump's voters in various
polls 80
more than one poll said this do not
believe the election was free and fair
so we're looking at something like 65
million people
or so 66 million people who think that
the election was rigged how many
americans do you think have ever
seen a baseball game where they knew the
other side was cheating
and they just thought to themselves sort
of like well
you know if you ain't cheating you ain't
trying yeah
that that's a that's a saying that's a
thing yep americans
they fight hard yeah so how much
is there a chance that if if they go
through
all of the legal process and everything
is exhausted
at the end of the day whatever the final
arbitration is it's like
for biden you don't think some of that
80 percent is just gonna be like well
we'll get them next time yeah yeah i
think that's i think that's very very
lifelessness so that's
that's it's conservatives i mean it's
it's conservative saying
well they're cheating and we know
they're cheating but you know whatever
so i'm trying to combine the
fecklessness you're describing with this
anticipatory
conflict that you're thinking about that
that we've gone off the precipice and
we're shattered i'm not saying
that whatever's happening is going to in
the immediate result
in you know marching armies or anything
like that or or
you know the republicans arming up and
saying you know
no confidence in the government or
whatever i'm saying
they literally are already having public
hearings outside of government
whatever that means i don't know but
they're doing it yeah
and and it wasn't like they they said
you know this is the official off-site
location like when they moved the white
house you know to the other buildings
i wish i could remember the name of that
octagon mar-a-lago winter white house
i'm talking about in like 1800's man you
know but just a temporary location they
didn't announce anything like it was
just really just a dog and pony show
where people with credible credible
people
came and gave their testimony but not
even testimony they're just sort of
so that's that's the other thing i was
saying early on that perhaps what they
were doing is just trying to calm down
the hulk
they were like we need to make sure that
republicans
grumble and go home and do nothing so
we're going to give them their hearing
you're not giving them a hearing in an
actual building are you fine we'll do it
at the window i guess
then they'll feel like we actually
listen to them
the republicans are like right now in my
opinion in pennsylvania look at this
they're the ones who pat passed act 77
which
created the universal the no excuse
mail-in voting system
which according to the lawsuit that's
actually got you know
that's gotten the certification frozen
unconstitutional it was republicans who
passed that
now in pennsylvania the republicans are
holding these like
you know it reminds me of that joke
where they said both the left and the
right have said this about biden or
trump
make a fake white house put you know
candidate in it
and then film a reality show where they
think they're president
so they're like let's set up a hearing
we'll do it at a hotel it won't be
official but we'll convince the
republicans we're actually looking out
for him
and you know i you know i don't uh know
pennsylvania politics so so well but uh
were the people those republicans were
they the old line establishment types
the neocon types were they or they're
not not maga
obviously i just wonder how that went
down
but you've mentioned a few times a
challenge that you think
has some legs right the unequal
treatment of the ballots and the voting
process and the care periods and things
like that so this is the crazy thing
the judges and pa are basically saying
burn the whole thing down we don't care
and it's it's almost like the rulings
they're giving are them looking
you in the eyes and saying no it's
totally fair what we're doing
and you're like what like these rulings
are just like i can't remember the
specific
case that i said the other day you have
to watch the other episode but it's it's
it's basically like we we've deemed that
uh this lawsuit is true and correct and
this is unconstitutional
but we're gonna allow it and then you
know we'll we'll call the legislature in
the future to do something about it
so it's like you you know that it was
bunk and something was bad
and you're gonna let it stand so what
happens when the judge said
what he said to giuliani what do you
expect me to do disenfranchise
you know seven million voters or
whatever and giuliani i guess he was
like
you know we don't know where these votes
came from in this case
the judges had they had two choices
if they agreed with giuliani and said
these seven hundred thousand votes are
hereby being
disqualified at the fault of the
pennsylvania government
for violating the election code oh now i
remember exactly what they said you're
gonna love this
the judge said the election code states
there must be observers
witnessing the uh observers present
to observe the ballot counting process
but it doesn't state a distance
therefore as long as they're in the
building it's up to code
no sane rational person looked at the
code and said that's the point of the
law
we know why the law was passed as it was
because you want someone to
observe the actual ballot the judge said
it doesn't say what distance
100 feet back so when they sued saying
we couldn't witness what was going on
the judge said you were in the building
right good enough
that's the election code that is them
laughing in your face when you
know what the point of the law was and
using a technicality sorry
it's true and fear incorrect and then
laughing and high-fiving their friends
i wonder if there's ever been a
circumstance in which we
on the right people were you know
pushing the pedal to the floor
in this regard i imagine there has to
have been i mean
george w bush iraq afghanistan
yeah them being like there's weapons
there's weapons trust us don't look
don't go by the curtain
and then the media lied and defended
them so look with the democrats right
now you get the media lying and
defending them
and guess what the media guess who the
media lied and defended in 2003.
george w bush and the republicans right
so it's it's the game is
the political establishment is a
well-oiled machine it's a big club
and you ain't in it do you actually
think these people would allow the
rabble
to dictate the course of human events
absolutely not right
donald trump being the rabble and the
rabble rouser
yeah i'm the leader of the rebel and the
one that we launched into dc to do the
things that he did
some of them at least i i i i mentioned
this before but i remember
being outside that building after trump
got elected and he comes in in the suv
and he's having a meeting with the old
guard republicans
and the rumor was he basically told him
to go after themselves he was the
president and do whatever he wants
and i'm sure the meeting went something
like now that you're president here's
the plan we have in place for what we
want you to do and he said no
i'm the president we're going to get
america back on track and they're like
trust us this is the plan he said no
they went nuts the never trumpers
erupted a bunch of republicans retired
it was basically a president who says
here's what the the people want
i don't care what you want and then the
intelligence agencies and the uh
establishment elites
you know were all simultaneously
drinking their tea and dropped their
glasses like oh
oh my watch the pearls yeah and that is
going to help the rebel
and they didn't have anything on him
like they had on the rest of them
because it would it would have come out
it would have come out and it did they
tried
they lied and they put up all these
ridiculous accusations it didn't happen
though
yep because because he was clean and
they didn't he wasn't in the club he
wasn't supposed to win
right and he did they hadn't soiled him
prior he wasn't like coming up the ranks
and getting
he was supposed to visit epstein island
before you know getting his opportunity
right you know
kidding by the way i don't think obama
you know this is a good time to bring up
maybe
uh the pardon today oh michael flynn
yeah
yeah
this is scary that's a scary stuff why
is it scary uh not the pardon oh uh i
think the partner was the right move
it's scary that judge sullivan so so
i'll give you the quick context
uh michael flynn was charged with lying
to the fbi but it was an informal
meeting he wasn't actually in an
official meeting under an official
investigation as far as he knew
he's hanging out the white house and
some guys in a question you ever talked
to kislyak and he was like no
and they're like gotcha you lied and
they said plead guilty otherwise we're
going after your son
and so he said okay once trump got
control of things he said
we're going to drop this case the judge
said no
they tried again judge sullivan started
prosecuting essentially
refusing the prosecution to drop their
case it makes no sense
and then here's the funniest part the
most infuriating thing
over the past month do you know what
judge sullivan has done nothing
nothing literally you know why sullivan
is waiting for joe biden to get in
so they can lock up michael flynn for no
reason
because he offended the delicate
sensibilities of the political
establishment by working with donald
trump that's it
they used him as a weapon against trump
they threatened his family
and trump is pardoning him now this is a
political civil war and
that language came from came from mother
jones yeah they said the political civil
war will carry on
when you have the obama administration
falsely
targeting a national an acting national
security advisor who was doing his job
targeting his family and we saw it from
the notes that got released the fbi said
what's our goal here to prosecute him or
get him fired
the fact that they even questioned
getting him fired proves that their
intention was just to hurt donald
trump's campaign
yes that's it or his administration yeah
and with the underlying motivation of
protecting themselves right because
flynn was the one who knew
where the skeletons were buried or which
closets the skeletons were in something
like that he knew
where the bodies were there we go yeah
he knew where the bodies were literally
and figuratively
yeah a hundred percent and uh it
definitely derailed things and it also
put trump in a really bad position
where he you know he fired him and then
he looked bad he didn't look loyal to
his people and he threw out sort of
uh a a dynamic guy who wanted to make
change in the right way who saw the
world the right way
was part of the whole team that was
supposed to make changes and that was a
huge fumble and a huge a huge win
basically for the democrats there and it
just reminds me actually of why the
presidential pardon exists in some cases
i mean
you had to people had to believe that
they would use the courts against your
political
you know allies as a way to get to you
so like of course people that support
the president are going to be attacked
and this is a way to you know maybe
protect somebody in that regard i'm not
an expert on president's pardon so i'm
just spitting yeah it does seem weird
that uh
he pled guilty then they tried dropping
it and it's like the case is already
it's like they'd already get to that
point like where were we at but it's
weird like you can pardon someone before
they've been investigated or charged or
something like
yeah i'm not i'm not an expert on that
all i know is i wish that he would have
done that sooner
brought him he wanted to get real he
didn't want to rock the boat
who was advising this guy if he would
have pardoned
flynn more people would have come out
and supporters if trump came out
in the first debate with the when they
said your last and final statement
i donald j trump i'm going to completely
legalize through executive order
on my first day of re-election january
21st
i will completely legalize cannabis
nationwide and pardon all non-violent
drug offenders
if that was that last thing he said like
120 million votes
i have been saying that since 2016 one
of the survey questions in
the survey i did for democrats are
deplorable the last question bonus
question
do you think that cannabis should be
decriminalized at the federal level
and it was like 75 to 25 percent of
democrats and deplorable voters
supported it it would have been a huge
win i called for it i even
told all my contacts in the white house
i've been pushing for it i mean don't
have the influence to get that done
but i tried i tried because it's a civil
liberties issue
it's a it's a civil rights issue you
know it's liberty
issue i mean also it's just seen and
smart so yeah and it generates a lot of
revenue through taxation i mean
it would have been it would it would
defang a lot of cartels which it already
started has started to do you know you
know what's really crazy
you know the cartels are selling now
i don't want to know is it getting worse
uh
make a guess they're selling so so now
barbra tall so now that now that pot is
basically recreational in many different
states yeah
you're wrong you're wrong it's way worse
way worse than that yeah avocados
no joke avocados really yep you know
they because avocados are extremely
like in demand lucrative you know
millennials love that avocado toast i
mean avocados are pretty awesome so
they're shaking down avocado farms now
it's more money
yeah i mean i i believe that 100 that
those guys aren't dedicated to the art
and the
the act of selling drugs they're just
trying to if they knew a guy that bought
bricks for 10 and
they could sell bricks for nine or buy
but they would do it they would do it
that way maybe not in that order
uh but yeah he could have done it he
didn't do it there's a lot of things he
could have done didn't do
i i don't know if i'm ready for the
post-mortem although i've been critical
of him every time that he needed it and
i've been supportive when he has
you know i i've never been one to come
out and just throw maga red meat and say
donald trump is the god savior and all
that
he he represented an opportunity for
us the network to make change
and i i think he was effective in some
ways in that regard and he certainly
certainly stalled some of the things
that we wanted to stall and slow
uh but was he perfect no and you know
the economic devastation that will come
to this country in the next uh
several months will be i believe it's
going to be
covet related you mean yeah yeah yeah
like it's going to be unimaginable
and then new administration tim you
really you really think that the covet
situation is going to be worse now than
it was
in march uh
based based on the fact that people are
already had already their legs chopped
off in march
and now they're coming for him again oh
fiscally humane yeah yeah yeah yeah the
lock the th so
they're destroying ownership no i mean
i'm telling you we got this uh
i got let me let me pull the story the
story of new covid policing unit
to launch in maryland on thanksgiving
eve they're uh
high visibility enforcement efforts
they're calling like they're calling
them like compliance units
state and local police to enforce
compliance
we're literally at a point where the
government against the direct
against the science and even in some
instances instances against the
direction of the cdc
are destroying the economy here's what
happens
have you noticed that dow jones hit 30
000 points today i sure did
yeah that's real good news for people
with money in
you know retirement or in their stocks
but younger people
and you know people who are lower class
just got cut off completely
like we're we're at a point where you
can see the stock market skyrocketing
while businesses are being are
collapsing wages are gone because the
jobs are gone
so joe biden says i'm gonna trust the
scientists on what we should do
and and who's his advisor is dr
osterholm who said lock the whole
country down for six weeks
remember fifteen days slow the spread
turned into you know 15 days
10 months and and the goal was just to
ease the burden on the icu
so that we didn't have a bunch of
secondary deaths
because of capacity overloads and one
thing that i have noticed
uh it looks as though that the second
wave in europe isn't resulting in the
same amount of deaths proportionately as
the first go-round
it also looks like they might be peaking
i i understand but just in terms of
the science and the data is going to
show a much more diminished effect
i think this time and you know they're
gonna have therapeutics and we have
treatment and knowledge
they're gonna they're gonna say oh
that's because the lockdown is working
we better double our efforts in in
greece if you wanna leave your house you
gotta text the cops
let them know why in france you got to
have your papers where
is the rapid disposable test
if we could just where's antifa what do
you mean
the anti-fascist to say the government
cannot come down and lock you in your
home right
no they're cheering for it i guess yeah
where are they where'd they go they'll
protest some fat old trump supporter
waving a flag
but they turn a blind eye when the
government comes that's locking people
in their houses
larpers with attitudes for sure but i
think
isn't a solution this a rapid test that
you can just take
every day or you can take it when you go
somewhere just test test all the time
what this is this would be they're
unreliable
we should be focusing on moving well so
i think what's going to end up happening
is
we've already saw it with uh i i think
it's pronounced contest or qantas i
don't know it's
q the australian airline if you want to
fly international you got to get your
vaccine
you got to have your your approved
vaccine status and ticketmaster
announced they would list vaccine status
on tickets
if the organizers wanted it so what's
going to happen is people are going to
be
like no one's forcing you to get the
covet vaccine but you can't do anything
you can't go to
the store because it's private business
right this is the same way that they
have really affected the quote lockdowns
as they just made it
so that there was nowhere for you to go
so i think
everything we're seeing is the rich
getting richer
the look man if you want to if if if i
had to
buy a stock right now i'd buy these
pharmaceutical stocks
you know got it people got to get the
vaccines
they're already saying they're going to
put vaccine status on on on cards
china wants qr codes on your phone for
the whole world because that's what
they're doing
so uh yeah so guess what company's gonna
make a ton of money i've seen v for
vendetta you you've seen me venetta
right
the guys who who uh who worked at lark
hill
bought all the stock in the
pharmaceutical company and then all
became ridiculously wealthy
i'm not saying there's anything
nefarious about the vaccine itself i'm
saying
they've got a government mandate they've
these companies got operation warp speed
and so these pharmaceutical companies
are like we got a guaranteed two billion
dollar contract
invest in that's money like the
company's gonna make money guaranteed
definitely let's talk a little bit more
i'm not familiar with the details of
warp speed are you
because only they only a little bit like
they basically offered up
guaranteed contracts to the companies so
some got direct funding
and i think uh pfizer got a guaranteed
contract and did they did they like
strip any of the regulations and
approvals or make it streamlined or
anything like that
i can vaguely say i think so because i
was just having this like i can't go
through the whole business
you know this realization today that
really the the fda and regulations and
clinical trials and all
that that is what's standing in our way
of ending all this all this
ending the lock down ending the social
well i mean we need to we need the
vaccine
yeah i'm saying do you watch utopia dude
i'm the one that told you
i know but like did you watch the new
one the new one i did not was different
in the new one there is a wealthy you
know biotech
guy who wants to create a world with no
racism or sexism or inequality
so he stages a fake pandemic so that
they can ram through a vaccine without
proper protocols
and then the vaccine actually just
sterilizes people right make people beg
beg to take the vaccine which is the
thing that actually sterilizes them
and then did have you seen nand yet uh
i saw it no it fell asleep i think but
uh the idea was
people would beg for it and not realize
for five or ten years
that the next generation so now in dc
there's a story you sent me
yeah they just they just uh approved ten
to three approved children can get
vaccinated without
the parents knowing yeah whoa so imagine
this
vaccines can have adverse reactions
that's a fact um
it's it the complications tend to be
rare but they do happen especially if
you've got
you know uh how many people live in dc
700 000
in in dc proper like three million maybe
three million no no just in dc probably
seven hundred thousand well actually i
guess if the kid lives outside of dc but
goes to school in dc that's
that could happen right it could so then
you've got uh
you know a couple hundred thousand kids
maybe potential there's like 80 000 kids
in the school district
in the school system dc so of this 80
000
there is possible uh complication that
might arise
for sure the mothers watching their kid
convulsing the floor screaming i don't
know what's going on i don't know what's
going on
she calls 9-1-1 and they say has your
son been given any medication no he
hasn't
okay and then they give the kid a
counterindicated medication and the kid
just explodes right in front of everyone
yeah figuratively i mean when i saw the
headline for that article i
didn't think it was true and it and i
watched the video
when you sent me the link of the video
time stamped for my dc city council like
approving some bill like that it made me
laugh that you were paying that close
attention to the dc council a bunch of
jokers
well when i saw that the the story came
out saying the dc city council has voted
they said they plan to finalize a vote
allowing children to get back as young
as 11 get vaccinated vaccinated without
parental consent
i looked up the hearing yeah and i
watched the video of them all
voting on it ten to three ten to three
yeah and it's not even just
that it's without parental consent but
it is a legitimate conspiracy to keep
parents
in uninformed where the the the doctor
can order the vaccinee vaccine
for the 11 year old who has given their
quote informed consent
right and then they bill the insurance
company without
notifying the parent and then when the
when the insurance companies send you a
statement
they can leave out the description of
benefits so you have no idea
what that service was so the whole
there's no paper trail there's no
anything you're completely cut out
when you go to the hospital they ask if
you've taken any medications recently
you know if you know and there and
there's probably they might tell the kid
like here's what you should or shouldn't
do after
getting this vaccine if the kid has some
kind of complication and the mom doesn't
know
the mom could do something very serious
that could harm the child yeah or or
just the fact that
how can you do that to my child what
what what troubles me
is establishing some notion that an 11
year old can give consent
now i have listen tim you know you know
that we know some people that have trade
and crazy theories and we know that
there's a universe out there for crazy
theories and there's one crazy theory
that i've never given any credence to
which is that
there's some sort of grooming a future
grooming of like
pedophilia right like making it okay for
for adults to have sex with kids which
is obviously the most disgusting thing
you can think of
and i've always discounted i've never
paid attention to it sure there's
there's instances
where children are molested assaulted
it's horrible terrible thing we must
stop it
but when you start defining legally the
fact that an 11 year old can give
informed consent to where else can they
give this level of consent at 11 years
old
do you know that a very popular social
media app created they had these
stickers work that would say like new
year's and like happy day
and there was one of them that said they
put out a video i think it was snapchat
i could be wrong
it said you know love knows no age
terrible
and people started saying uh what do you
mean
like yeah it's not like maybe you're
trying to say like if you're 50 and
you're dating someone who's 20
it's kind of weird but like it's legal
but like you're going the wrong way with
this one because that's not what people
hear exactly and so when i brought this
up to some of my friends and family
about this new law in dc which luckily
has only passed the council it still
needs mayoral execution which is
probably going to get but then
luckily in dc we don't have home rule
for real
and so the final law gets approved by
congress i've already started lobbying
sympathetic congressmen
as a way to get senate and uh no it just
gets approved by the house
they're gonna approve it it's democrats
true but there are ways there are ways
to to to do i've seen independent
renegade acting isolated representatives
in the house
affect dcu law because it was their pet
issue they find ways through amendments
or whatever the case may be so i started
lobbying people because i can't let this
happen i tried to explain
to my friends and family what it meant
and they read it
and then they just they come back with
the most charitable
charitable like oh well maybe they
didn't word it the right way or that's
not exactly what they
mean exactly right it's the same thing
when you send people to the old
blm website where it said that they
wanted to disrupt the nuclear family and
blah blah blah i got rid of that now i
know they did yeah and and
you i sent the um the guy that uh that
live streamed the the portland murder
i interviewed him for like an hour and a
half going through his tape back and
forth and at the end
trying to ask him why are you doing this
he's like my daughter's got me roped
into it not roped into it she's teaching
me about it whatever
i was like do you know what it says
you're a family man you're a dad
you you're the center of your family and
you're taking care of your kids and you
believe in the power of fatherhood and
the nuclear family
let's read what it says on black lives
matter website about disrupting the
nuclear family and he read it and he was
like oh they just probably had a bad
editor
it's like they people won't just read
the plain
language on the paper this is a man
the the throne was seized a long time
ago by this ideology
and it's interesting because we had uh
hotep jesus on
yeah how was that he was great he was
great um and he was basically saying
that ian was a pessimist
and that ian didn't trust in people and
that's why
like you know it was it was interesting
to say because ian's usually much more
optimistic
but the general idea is the people who
have
who are in positions of power the
established establishment
they think that people are better off
being told what to do instead of being
given the freedom to do it
michael bloomberg is the perfect example
when he said tax the poor and i don't
mean that hyperbolically he literally
gave a speech about taxing the poor
being the right thing to do
he said we need to tax the poor because
they make terrible decisions
and if we have their money and make the
decision for them they'll be better off
to varying degrees i understand what
he's trying to say i can agree in some
capacity
the problem is the bigger picture is a
decentralized network deciding for
itself will
be infinitely smarter and faster moving
and better than a command economy
yeah i i'm much more in favor i'm in
favor of a mixed economy
like we definitely need a government
that can say hey whoa wow that was a
really bad thing we did
you know the market's going crazy we
need to figure this out before
everything goes nuts
but i don't so i'm not a large fair
capitalist but i also don't think a
command economy with one person
dictating what you should or shouldn't
do makes sense
these people do so bloomberg passes the
tax on sugary drinks
it's like no dude like you you need a
cultural shift
to get people to do to do better you
can't just mandate you can't drink soda
you know what i mean
right you you figure out the right way
to get people
uh uh like i don't know it's got it's
got to be a cultural shift it's got to
be based upon
giving people the choice to do the right
thing taxing
things but but giving people the choice
to do quote the right thing but
comes with the acceptance that
people are going to do the wrong thing
yep and being prepared for that and
being willing to live with those
consequences are you an optimist or a
pessimist
an optimist would say i think that in a
long enough period of time
humans have the house advantage 51-49
so the way a casino works is sure they
don't care if you win
they love it when you win good it's
marketing for them they want you to
cheer and so everyone hears you winning
and then makes them gamble more
because in a long enough time frame the
house always wins because their edge is
you know over a point
that's this the same thing in terms
that's how i view
giving people free choice we've proven
consistently that on a long enough time
frame humans
tend towards succeeding very well
actually
and these people don't believe it these
people think humans don't have the edge
and need to be constrained
and that has led to disaster every time
it's been tried
every single time yeah one one thing
that works just as well as success being
rewarded is
failure being you know consequences for
failure right so people make dumb
decisions they don't have to make them
decisions for very long
unless of course we're all going to
socialize their negative you know their
bad decisions which is when you get into
that hybrid space
where you give people the freedom to do
what they want then when they make the
bad decision then you have to pick them
up and take care of them
i remember my dad used to describe to me
welfare he's like son do you want people
bang on your door looking for bread
or you want to just give it to them it's
not a bad not a bad thought
with that being the assumption that
there was always going to be people
looking for bread right
yep the way the way i put it is
they say you know if you uh if you give
a man a fish you feed him for a day if
you teach a man a fish you feed him for
the rest of his life
well the left often says like you can't
lift yourself up by your bootstraps if
you don't have any boots
and i'm like yeah it's really simple you
teach a guy to fish and a fishing rod
and say have at it
and that's the end of it yeah give them
the means to do the fishing
so there's certain things so so that's
why i'm you know left leaning in certain
like i'm independent left leaning a bit
cause like yeah we'll take a person you
know they're struggling
teach them to fish give them the fishing
rod you know we can't take care of you
forever
but we can do our best to help you out
you know i've i've gotten uh
unemployment
benefits when i was in my 20s and it
saved my life kept me from being you
know homeless
yeah so i think these can be good things
the problem is when people get addicted
to them
and it's just easier to stay on than
than to get off yeah and so
now what we're seeing with the coveted
lockdowns is that
instead of figuring out a way to survive
a lot of people are just screaming for
the government to print more money
and that's literally calling for the
destruction of your economy they don't
care
it's just people screaming to extract
more from the machines
they just they don't care 99 of people
in america
can't even like point out where
washington dc
is on the map much less understand the
long-term ramifications of increasing
the money supply
you know right so who knows right but
maybe we're facing a huge demand
shortage so deflation is our biggest
enemy
i don't know i did just see the house
prices in dc are going up
there's a huge spike in real estate
activity so some
i think the rich the rich are going to
have are it's the greatest it's the
greatest thing in the world man
if you're if you're rich think about
what this means
they're going to decimate the economy
the lockdown and then you can go buy
all that property up two things happen
for one the interest rates are in the
gutter
because they're like oh no the economy
oh the interest rates drop everything
down and so
you can buy up all this property and get
a great rate and the property value is
tanking in a lot of places especially in
new york
and then what happens when they're like
we've just deployed the vaccine and the
property values skyrocket
back up again the economy collapses the
rich people buy everything up and then
it comes back and now they control
everything
and he comes and goes and waves they
keep doing it so poor people lose
everything
they're struggling begging for help and
the rich are getting richer
bezos is net worth skyrocketing amazon's
value skyrocketing all these big
companies
all their revenue everything's
skyrocketing because they lock down
small business
it's uh you know people are fighting
back i saw a little bit i saw
i saw like a burger shop who was defying
uh the codes and doing gofundmes for the
fees for the for the the fines
yeah and i saw another gym owner who
refused at the rate of like fifteen
thousand dollars
yeah he's like he tore it up i think
right yeah yeah you know we we need we
need more of that and
and i recommend action like that where
you're directly
if you're going to protest confronting
the rule enforcer or the rule maker that
is legitimately
authorized by the government don't put
your local hostess at the restaurant in
a hard spot by refusing to wear a mask
or
not complying don't be that jerk you
know it's not her decision dude just
make her life easier it sucks for her
too you know
i understand wearing masks i understand
wearing masks when you're going shopping
i don't understand masks when you go to
a restaurant and you walk in
and they say right this way and then
they set you down and take your mask
right off
well dude now uh in dc the restaurants
are like
you have to have your mask on the whole
time the whole time you're not eating
any time the weight staff approaches the
table you must put your mask on
and i went out the other night and and
i'm eating and i've got the cloth
napkin it's like a really thick nice
white napkin and there
they come up with the next drink and
they just kind of stand there
sheepishly from like six feet away and i
went like this and instead of putting a
mask on i just went like this with the
with the napkin you know and then the
guy's like that's not how you do it
that doesn't work he goes it's dirty i'm
like what do you mean it's dirty just
like masks it's all dirty everything's
dirty it's like
you're doing it wrong you're doing it
wrong and my girlfriend
told me you know these people think that
they're risking their lives yeah
they've been lied to you they're risking
their lives by doing this service for
you
and that they're at risk of dying if i
don't
if the difference between me putting up
a cloth napkin
versus a cloth face mask is making
people insane it makes me not want to go
out
it makes me know how do you hang out
with people like that you know i don't i
don't know anybody who's like that
you don't because i mean they don't come
here i know they exist i've talked to
them but like
my my circle of friends and and family
they just don't they're just not like
that yeah you see that that funny meme
it says uh uh it's like normal people
and it's a guy wearing that
gigantic it's it's a gigantic thing you
put over your your head
and it's got a vent that pulls air in
it's like a clear front and a big
and it's like you're going underwater it
says like it's like normal people and
then under it says conspiracy theorists
and it's people smiling and having
turkey
and thanksgiving exactly yeah yeah isn't
that oh actually i can pull it up
because i think
i think mike cernovich oh we have the
meme yes one second to find the meme
isn't that the thing the conspiracy
theorists are the ones who want to have
school open and the ones who want to
have thanksgiving and travel and get
back to work and open up the economy
tim if you were an 85 year old
grandmother
with 12 grandchildren all in grade
school right now and you thought
yourself you had
two or three years left of life would
you demand
that your grandchildren be deprived
of their senior prom and their varsity
last varsity year of sports
and hanging out with their friends so
that you can live out one or two
extra years of your life no of course
not
no one would no grandmother would why
don't we let the grandparents decide on
the lockdown
you got to see this thing here this is
this is the meme normal people
look at this thing this guy's wearing
like jack can't see it at all so so
normal people aren't really wearing
these things this is like a weird
marketing thing people are trying to do
but then conspiracy theorists it's like
grandma like giving the turkey and
grandma's like
everyone's clapping and happy and
yeah man people they tell you what they
they they accuse you
of what they're doing yep yeah it's
basically it's very it's wrong
and it's working and so if the
republicans
are sitting there with their feet up
smoking cigars being like dude
i don't want to be involved i'm just
happy to get paid
and so you've got one side when we had
hotep jesus on
he was talking bad about the democrats
and i was like we do that we we smack
talk democrats all the time oh yeah and
i was like
what do you think about republicans and
he said something like i don't know that
the republicans are doing anything that
i could actually
complain like i actually like talk about
it all like what do they do
and i'm like they don't do anything
they're literally just sitting around
pretending to fight i guess how many
hearings have they had on big tech
censorship and done nothing about it
oh those republicans yes i don't mean
the people yes okay no i mean the
politicians yeah yeah
i know the democratic politicians are
doing trash but the republican
politicians are like we're fighting for
you and then they sit down and they
we hate them all right we hate them all
the maga movement has no respect for the
gop we hope it dies and disintegrates
and blasts into a million billion
trillion pieces
and we can truly point the finger at
them as the limiting factor
in many ways in trump's success so no
love lost there i was never republican
the book isn't democrat to republican
right
right it's democrats are deplorable you
should you should write a new one called
uh
deplorable to ugly chumps ugly chumps
that's what biden called them he's
called them ugly chumps i'm an ugly
trump but i bet
i bet i could be biting in the push-up
contest yeah you sure could
yeah yeah yeah you probably could did
you know that biden gave a speech today
or something
nope nobody did
politics forget about politics tim i'm
gonna
i'm gonna move on skate videos do it i
wanna know first of all i think that you
should lay down seven more tracks
and put out an album i think that that
first song that i heard
blew my mind no offense exceeded all my
expectations
the video was fantastic you can play and
sing
and it's on point and we need art
we need art like that we need videos and
movies and books and literature
and music and music videos so tim you
should do that i've often wondered
coming up here so many times so it's
like 10 times i've been up here yeah
and i and i wonder you know where are
you going to go tim you're you're
younger than me you're 13 14 years
younger than me probably
how old are you i'm 45. i'm 34. 34. okay
11 11 years younger than me
you've got this whole youtube empire
built you're doing great
you're you're fulfilled and i'm
wondering where are you going to go what
are you going to do next
and it sounds like you're starting to
make some moves man you just scale them
back just a little bit all the time
scaling back just a little bit and going
to start doing some other problems we're
not scaling up scaling back actually
on the videos i mean we're on the
politics because we're going to be
right right right so i mean maybe we'll
see what happens
uh i've taken it you know i think uh the
day after
uh it was a sunday after election i took
the day off like for the first
the first literal i'm taking a day off
i've never done that before
the only times i've ever had office
because like i lost my voice or i had to
get like a tooth you know fix or
something
and so i had no choice to take a day off
that this was literally me being like
i'm gonna go ride my bike and then
i rode my bike 32 miles and people are
like that's not a day off dude it's like
you rode your bike 32 miles it was it's
awesome it was intense
no it was brutal i was like after like
20 miles
you know i had 12 left i just kind of
like my brain shut off yeah because i
couldn't stop in the middle of the woods
there's nothing you can do there's no
you can't call anybody you can't get a
ride it's like you either get on your
bike and you finish the 12 miles or you
just sit in the woods forever that's
awesome man so it was like my legs felt
like
it was a weird feeling but it felt like
i was ripping them to shreds tim that's
amazing and
i want all of you guys out there
listening to this to take note
get outside exercise get your heart rate
going
bro look at trees
when was the last time you guys saw a
freaking tree man
get out there you gotta get out there
for your sanity and to connect with
nature and reset yourself
well we're going to hear that so i want
to know more though we're going to start
doing events
uh i don't know what's going to happen
because the lockdown stuff is getting
crazy is getting crazy
but we're probably going to do uh right
now within the guidelines like
we can have events you know we don't
have 100 people we just have like you
know maybe
20 people which is apparently fine but
we're also in the middle of nowhere so
like no one's coming out here
but uh the goal is to just do some
events and and start filming videos
and uh the vlog channel is going to be
more
just fun and shenanigans i guess good
just just just to like
uh it's a combination of for one
things things are going to start it
depends on what happens i guess if
if you know all hell breaks loose in the
next month or so you know the reason why
i i do political commentaries because
there's too much talk about there's just
so much going on all the time right
but i also think it's uh expanding the
business
i can only do so much as an individual
and if i'm going to create
different you know verticals different
uh you know genre
content channels so i the vlog channel
was planned a long time ago this this
channel
right now was originally the vlog but
then covet happened
nice so i was like we couldn't get i
couldn't find the vlogger it was too
hard to do covet happened so we're like
we'll just do a talk show i guess
now it's like okay now now we gotta get
the vlog going talk show is
relatively easy to do because we we
you know we've been hearing the news all
day we sit down we have a conversation
you have great guests
my my best guess the six segments i do
on my other channels tim cast and tim
cass news those are those are harder
a lot harder to produce yeah so i don't
script anything but it is
reading for hours non-stop in the
morning all day all night constantly
just pulling things up
and uh doable but it's intense
yeah you have amazing retention i
remember everything it's just
yeah i like it i like it sometimes when
i'm riffing on just
bigger picture issues you stop and
you're like well no and then there's
this process and then this thing and
that thing and that thing i'm like sweet
i read that's exactly what i need
hundreds of articles a day probably yeah
and so the reason why
you get into this groove where i read
everything so it's like when i see a
story and they say you know
donald trump declares x i say oh wow
because he declared y
back then which means this and then you
can pull that stuff up
i do think it's funny when i see like
i'll notice something
and there's there's oftentimes as much
as the left won't admit they hate
admitting it or they don't actually
watch my content there's a lot of stuff
that i report that's fairly original
and then i see it right you know pop up
and a bunch without saying similar
things and then you know
becomes a meme or something yeah yeah so
but
at a certain point you know it's like
political commentary i feel like is just
one direction that has
its cap and if i'm gonna expand the
business and do more that means
i gotta leave the charge so that's one
of the one of the biggest challenges
there's no what do they call it like a
turnkey business where it's like you
click the button walk away and the
business makes money yeah it doesn't
work in this industry or
any i mean but no i mean like the idea
is it was from
watching a king of the hill episode
where uh you know econ buys a
car wash a turnkey business you you set
it up people go there they put the money
in the machine they use the car wash
they leave yeah and then you come back
ever you know you know
every every night you pick up the money
and then you go to pause in the bank and
repair the machines and pay the
insurance
right right but you're not there
managing a day-to-day basis i know yeah
it's just sort of a myth this idea that
there's a business that runs itself
passive income isn't hardly passive at
all and you definitely need to lead the
charge expand right
expand i mean do you think that there's
a social emotional toll
on focusing on on on the conflict and
chaos and politics all the time
does it get to you ever no i've been
because i've been focused on it my
entire life
yeah because i got i was i would because
i was 14 9 11 happens
yeah then we get all the war stuff all
of the music videos all the celebrities
everything they're screaming in my face
barack obama comes around we're gonna
end these wars i vote for him and he
lied to me
so it was like it was endless it was
endless so i started working for
non-profits yeah and then it was
literally endless i'll tell you what man
i worked for a nonprofit in california
and it was when the deepwater horizon
thing happened when the oil spill
happened in the gulf yeah
and they gave us this fact sheet so i'm
waving to people and i'm like i was like
hey we got a serious disaster right did
you hear what happened in the gulf like
deep water horizon erupted we're trying
to get funding
for awareness we need support and people
will be like wow i didn't know that we
had pictures and everything
and then one day i waved to a guy and i
say
here's what's happening here's how much
has spilled and he goes that's not true
and i was like what what he goes that's
not true it
hasn't spilled that much the actual
amount of spill is like you know it's
like 10 times less
and i was like oh and i was like why are
you lying to me and i was like i
no i just what they gave me like yeah
why did they give you lies and then i
got really angry
called up my boss right away and said yo
some guy just told me i was lying i just
looked it up
this isn't true like you told us to go
and raise money this is not true
and he goes um yeah
you know uh well just keep keep using it
and
i was like you're asking me to commit
fraud like to lot knowingly lie to
someone to get them to give me money i'm
not doing that
they fired me good for you tim well i
mean i can't i'm
i'm like i'm not gonna go to jail for
this like i know i'm lying to you but
give me your money anyway
yeah people lie and get money all the
time without going to jail so good on
you there's been a vigilante in you
forever i imagine
well so that was that was you know i
worked for non-profits and then
eventually i was like these companies
they're just companies they're
non-profits they're companies they have
a bottom line they want to make money
and there's like the you know what i
learned the
the real non-profits the real charities
are the small ones
where it's like a dude who picks up a
bunch of hot meals and drives them
around
himself to uh yeah it's like a church
they drive around hot meals to
to people who are hungry and to the
elderly that's a
those are the real charities then you
see all these like tv charities and
these big brand charities
look at joe biden's charity right they
gave zero towards cancer research was a
foundation supposed to give out grants
they gave like nothing
it was all salaries like just like big
six figure salaries
that's i'm not gonna i'm not gonna make
any accusations but let me tell you
something
if you get dirty money if you need to
take some dirty money you do
you start a charity right
if you gotta pay out dirty money you
hire people you know for that charity
you pay him a salary and then once it
runs out you shut it down exactly right
cleaned
exactly right yeah i'm not saying that's
what he did i'm just saying
you know it's easy to do and it happens
all the time and there's all kinds of
nonprofits like that operating in
washington dc
and you know you people get paid they
pay taxes but it's tax deductible for
the donors
which makes it a nice thing for them
it's
it's better than than paying someone
directly it's not taxes you know
so it's tax advantaged it's all game to
him
all of it is a game i teach my son at a
very young age
he he learned to ask who's
who's getting paid where is the money
going what does alex jones always say as
a key bono
kibano yeah it's like benefits yeah who
benefits yeah exactly
yeah so my even my son at like eight
nine was like somebody somewhere is
getting paid
yeah true someone's finding something
from this
so so you know when it comes to the
political commentary stuff
it's like uh
i'm doing more than anybody else we
could this show
is the most fun
out of any of the commentary i do yeah
so it's like as long as we keep booking
people and keep
you know doing stuff like this it's a
lot less stressful it's a lot more fun
and engaging
yeah and uh it requires me to like
i'm not as like so much time is consumed
on my other show which is an hour and 45
minutes a day
of political commentary and various news
stories and that's a lot harder to
produce and and uh yeah
it's tough but it's funny i do the
opposite
so for me like coming here you're right
easy easy to
uh not have to prepare a whole lot uh
for my
interview show like i will i spend
probably 10 hours preparing for each
interview
read the art read their latest book read
their latest commentary be up to speed
and go slow and like get into it and i
wish i could put out two or three of
those a week but
i can only do them in bursts like eight
and ten at a time over like two or three
weeks and then i'm just exhausted
because it's so much work
i love it though not complaining so
here's the other thing uh when i was
covering stuff on the ground i would
walk like 10 miles 20 miles a day in
some instances
it was great i was doing parkour like no
joke during occupy wall street what made
me
effective in live streaming was that i
could run through a packed crowd
you get a packed crowd of a thousand
protests in the street and i could move
through it as if there was no one
there because i was like jumping left
right crouching going you know going
under people's arms and stuff
and then finding the spaces jumping over
things and then you
spend so much time the past couple years
just sitting in a chair all day every
day i'm trying to skate as much as
possible but
man is it it just feels bad i've been
i've been
extremely physically physically active
my whole life skateboarding since i was
younger
and uh so i just skate eight hours a day
just endlessly
just gaunt and covered in sweat not able
to eat like i used to eat a ridiculous
amount like 10 000 calories a day just
to keep up with skating
that's how intense it was now i'm
sitting in a chair and it's like
this is awful you know it's just it's
too much but the problem is
i can't even go to the dmv to get like
my license updated because i work
literally until
4 30 from the morning and then i eat get
some exercise and then prepare for this
show and i'm like
that's not that's not that's untenable
at a certain point
it was it was it worked out for the past
two years because we had the midterms
until the 2020 election but now i'm like
you mentioned that music video right i
wrote that song
i wrote the story the music video
everything it's based on i executive
produced it so basically
the the the animation directors the
animators in the studio
who put it together they did a bunch of
brilliant stuff like the color changes
each different political faction has a
different color
but uh basically they'd send it back to
man say here's what we need to do here's
what we need to do so one of the things
we did was
they they added something that's really
interesting at one point
in the at the last verse as a science
and the tv says don't trust the wolf
something they just added and then i
said make the kid
holding a stuffed wolf animal in the
under the bed so now it's like
yeah nice and so basically i came to
them with a story i dictated it
they were like uh nishiro recorded me
telling the story what the
song is going to be basically what it is
and then i
performed it wrote the lyrics and then
you know helped like produce the video
there's a ton of other ideas i have for
a bunch of really great short films and
documentary stuff that
i've never been able to produce so
at a certain point if i want to actually
expand i have to stop hyper focusing in
one area slow you know pull back and
then dedicate more time in another area
yeah so if i do only two of these
segments a day instead of six
that would be great i would be doing my
show would be cut down to about
uh my main podcast would be about 50
minutes
50 to 55 minutes and down from an hour
and 45
this show would be exactly the same but
that means i could finish up way earlier
and that means i can spend more time
shooting the vlog content
selling merch making cool stuff playing
with lasers and gadgets
also though hiring people to do
documentary films
like doing legit long-form documentary
stuff real impactful stuff
sending out a crew to go and cover a big
political issue and giving them like a
decent budget and stuff
that requires oversight so that's kind
of the
part of the plan moving into management
tim i mean
to a degree yeah yeah so it's it's like
i mean what
it's it's it's that's what happens well
it's not that it's what it happens like
man
it's just like i i'm at this point where
if i just do the exact same thing i do
every day six segments then this show
that's the plateau how do you expand
beyond that you can't you can't
if i'm the person who's physically doing
it all i can't hire someone to
commentary for me i can't be like you
know hey you you talk fast here come sit
here and record the segment frame only
um i can create a channel where we have
a variety of hosts who do certain things
so
there's definitely plans for more
content but that means i have to free up
some of the time throughout the day
to bring on more people to do more stuff
yeah and so part of it is
i'm gonna have more time to for one
exercise
skate but we're gonna film that and
we're gonna use that for
a brand and merchandise and just having
fun and at the same time
that's you know i could i could still
theoretically do all that right now
because i have that about hour every day
but then i want to do uh like that music
video need time to record music
more importantly though i got some
really great ideas for short films
and documentaries and you got to expand
your creative horizons and make time
we gotta we gotta launch the uh uh so
here's what i've been saying to people
for a long time covet cove
caused this problem it was two years ago
the plan was to launch an actual brand
and then covet happened and everything
went
and just like was a sledgehammer to all
the plans
tim poole stops at a certain point you
know i've gotten i've gotten
beautiful offers from big companies that
would have set me up for life
and i'm like yeah but you know i got to
be honest like
i don't think i think a lot of a lot of
people who work at some of these
companies who
so i've been to these big podcasting
companies and they're like here's what
we're offering you and i'm like i don't
think you're as good as business as i am
you're as good
at business as i am i think if i was in
charge of this with no contracts and
nothing holding me down i'd make way
more money
so at a certain point i need to create a
brand that can house
more than just me and my name so i can
bring on people who i think have talent
who need a place to get that you know
step up opportunity or whatever
people who are really good at something
but don't know how to get that path
forward
so you're a capitalist in the capital
sense of the world at this point well
not that you weren't but i'm saying but
i'm saying moving moving to
you trading your labor for using your
capital and putting that to work
yeah i know a lot of people who uh have
some skills that they probably can't
market like it's how skateboarding works
for instance
pro skateboarders are struggling right
now because the industry has changed
dramatically it used to be
you got uh you got a sponsorship from a
company you say you go pro you have your
you have your pro model it's a board
with your name on it
that board is sold in stores and you get
you know a dollar every time a board
sells
but you might sell a lot all over the
country with millions of skateboarders
tens of millions
you know or more you might sell a decent
amount and you're gonna get paid well
but you also have magazine spots they
call it photo incentive
so if you appear in a magazine doing a
trick and you can see the board
they cut you a check for 500 bucks right
on the spot well it's changed now
nobody reads magazines they used to put
out promo videos like the video drops at
this point they still kind of do they
still do
but instagram happened youtube happened
now the highest paid
professional skateboarders in the truest
sense of the word are not even that good
they're just fun to hang out with so you
watch their video and it's a dude who
can skate in his buddies and they're
doing funny things and having a good
time
and it's entertaining and they sell way
more boards than some of the biggest
companies that were like the pro and
best skaters
yeah so but pro skaters don't know how
to
they don't know what how to you know
actually sell the value of their skills
right and so what happens is a company
says we know
that if we film you we're going to sell
boards
so you don't got to worry about it
otherwise you don't make any money at
all
right that's capitalism right you know i
think the left doesn't understand that
you can't just take a skateboarder back
we're going to pay you but north korea
does
no for real they've like this is the
craziest thing about north korea they
have skate parks
and there are kids who are told like
your job will be to be to be a
skateboarder
and then we'll make sure you always have
your board and you go to the skate park
and you skate and get good
nice that's crazy anyway the point is
but tim
i think the moral of the story here for
you is is in today's day and age and
especially with the audience that you've
built
already do do what's fun
and your your audience is going to go
with you well i mean i don't
they don't there's an obligation and i
think the oh they support you they love
you dude that's what i mean
there's there's a lot that do and
there's a lot that just casually watch
for sure
but i think the uh the point is i mean
regardless figure out a way to do it
do your thing you know so it's it's
really funny because i got people smack
talking me
you know they're always talking to mac
like uh as if
as if somehow i all of a sudden one day
came into money and i was like dude i
used to work for disney like this was
six years ago i worked for disney do you
think they pay nothing like no
disney paid stupid money yeah like uh
there there was one instance
where uh i'm just gonna i'll just come
on say cause i got no problem talking
about it i was trying to break my
contract because they went full sjw
and i was like i don't produce this
stuff and one day i woke up with 40 000
my bank account i was like what is this
and they were like oh it's it's your
bonus and i was like for what
like i'm not doing what you want me to
do they were like you know just uh
just uh and i'm like uh-huh sure and
then sure enough it came time for my
contract
my contract yeah yeah it was it was
let's grease the wheels a little bit
buddy why don't you produce some of this
progressive
sjw whatever and i'm like nah
and so then when my contract came came
due they were like so and i was like
so i'm like okay um have a nice day yeah
i'm like
later yeah so so i've i you know and i
had to figure out like
i've saved a bunch of money over the
years working hard every day
every day consistent hardest working man
in this whole medium
i say it all the time so i started i
started a business i started youtube
and i flew to europe and i flew to
sweden and that cost a lot of money i
didn't make that money back for a while
so i had this money saved up i invested
it and started doing that went down that
route
and then started doing more and more and
it's funny because people think like we
bought this really
i bought this really big house and
people are like wow tim must have won
the lotto i'm like dude i was trying to
buy this property
a year and a half ago and then covet
happened so uh it was
it was a year and a few months ago i was
doing i was touring buildings
trying to find it our sale fell through
and then
like winter hit and made everything
really hard to go and check things out
but then when covid
happened it was like that was the end of
it so then when it came
to you know at a certain point we were
on like a hiatus for like four or five
months i was like now we gotta we gotta
force this through
by however by whatever means necessary
because otherwise we're just sitting
here doing nothing and it's the same
thing every single day yeah
now we have the house we're not quite
set up i got good news what's that
gigabit internet will be here in three
weeks
gigabit so no more uh internet cutting
out when we do shows
or can can i
tim texted me a couple weeks ago he's
like dude you have good internet i'm
like
yeah i'm like that's like a week ago
yeah i'm like i'm like yeah i got good
internet's like
can i give you an 83 gigabit file to
upload
he was going to drive it to my house so
that we could upload it was on my 75
up and down and now yeah yeah so uh
i had i had i had it driven to uh philly
where we have gigabit
it was faster because it would have take
so i i set it to upload overnight it's
like 15 hours to upload
and then it crashed of course browser
crash and i'm like so i tried it again
whatever browser crashed faster to drive
there and back and
drive there upload it and drive back it
was like four four or so hours
to drive there but then it uploads in 10
minutes right so it's just like
might as well just send someone out that
was the sunday special with ben shapiro
which is really funny because these like
a lot of these lefties who are like
the the leftist youtube people they're
man i gotta say they're low information
people like
they're not good at connecting the dots
and i don't know if it's just the active
twitter people who do it or whatever
but they're like they're spreading this
meme around that i refuse to have people
on my show because we don't have good
enough internet
or something like that i don't do skype
but that i did a skype with ben shapiro
and i'm like
i didn't i recorded it hard to the
camera
and then i sent the file to be uploaded
it was like
uh i'm honored it was i thought it was a
good show but it was it was like we did
a a standard call low res like
not broadcast quality conversation where
i could hear him
and then he would ask and then i would
answer and then i took the hard file and
had to upload it because
uh it was long story short first of all
we don't have actually is there a screen
anywhere in front of you jake no screen
sometimes i wish there was
i have this little monitor down here i
have this little monitor down here
and we have multiple people and we're
not set up in any way for skyping
and the internet can't handle two
streams up and down it's bad enough that
our internet cuts out could you imagine
if in the middle of our guest cuts out
we can't come back
no so i'm just like dude we we're not
designed for that but i'll tell you
something else man
online interviews are a waste of time
i'll get out of here dude it's my bread
and butter and i think i've gotten
really good at it
they're they're it's well okay fine to
be fair
there's a big difference between like
we're talking and then you can
you can i can see how you i can see it
in your eyes i can see in your face
you might be like wait hold on you'll
interrupt me when it comes to online
stuff it's like i ask you answer
i wait you ask i answer i wait it
becomes
it's good for probably an interview on
facts and data and stuff like that
but when it comes to having a real
conversation there's nothing that beats
sitting down with people yeah no i i
agree in person is very good
that said i think you know in my defense
jack rippy live on youtube baby uh i can
i can i think
reach a good creative spot with somebody
on on a you know
remote interview well i think i think
you've done like the thing you did with
matt brainerd was
was significant important yeah that
interview on the
you know so that's the voter integrity
fund finding you know actual evidence
and looking at the data
so you know it's better better to do it
than you know if you can't get someone
in person do it right yeah definitely
uh you know the sound quality must have
been really good when you did it the way
that you had done it because you had
hard live recordings in each places and
then they just merged
the video everything was pristine
perfect quality and i'm like did you not
realize that i had a
4k video no no artifacting
perfect audio it was 83 gigs and then we
sent it out for upload and then they
edited them together
yeah yes some people noticed they're
like yeah i realized it sounded like you
were you were reading answers
like you were giving your answers to
specific questions i'm like right
because
that's the only way we could really you
know we could really do it
you know i guess the other issue too is
like first of all
i don't go on anybody's shows but i made
an exception for ben shapiro because you
know he's been shapiro
it's a big show and uh i've interviewed
him in the past and so he hit me up and
i was like yeah okay you know
like but there's a lot of show i won't
go on people's shows for the most part
yeah
i i got very little time at all and and
so that
that that that was it i woke up at eight
you know i'm sorry i woke up at seven
uh reading the news start recording you
know start start my research
you know from from eight to four thirty
recording and everything and then from 4
30
until six or whatever it was setting up
and doing the recording for ben
then once i was done i grabbed a bite to
eat came upstairs and we did the next
show
grind and grind and grind and one thing
one of the reasons i don't do
other shows one thing you've been
talking about which i think is good for
people to remember is like you have to
be very mindful
with your time you have to be very like
deliberate with your decisions around
your time and time management
i personally have been working to try to
make sure that i
say no to enough things so that i can
say yes to the things that are important
to me
i've had i've had some pretty big shows
and i'm just like
yeah i can't do it the the traditional
ones i used to ignore like when i when i
get hit up by like
you know fox news i don't want to call
them out but i'm just like
there's literally no upside for me to
spend my time
like if you want to offer me a hard
contributorship they pay they pay
millions of dollars some of these people
it's
insane to get to get a guarantee like if
we hit up at this time you got to come
on
but i wouldn't i wouldn't do any of
those deals man i think i think it's a
bad idea
if i had you know a podcast network i've
had them come at me
and i've had networks be like
massive massive offers you know just
like
rich for life kind of offers and i'm
like nah it's not it's not worth it
it's not i wouldn't do it i went down
that route with uh with disney and it
was a mistake
so you know we'll see how it plays out
for you know
there's some other shows that took big
deals hmm
not gonna mention any names no but uh
you know
i think i kind of feel like i mean no
sure i'll say i mean it's pointless not
to but i think
you know i think joe rogan took the
spotify deal because where the wall
street journal journal reported it was
like 100 million dollars
yeah i think it's gonna it's gonna slice
away the overwhelming majority of his
audience
on december 1st joe rogan is going
exclusive on spotify
so he's gonna he's gonna be it's gonna
be a major boost to spotify
but he's gonna be off itunes you know
what happens when someone
for the first time opens the itunes app
to find a podcast joe rogan yeah of
course
that's that's that's the best real
estate in the podcasting world that he's
losing but
for good reason i mean yeah you know so
but there there is a
analogous situation here in in
broadcasting history if you remember
howard stern yep howard stern how's he
doing
wild i mean he's still rich right wildly
popular
am radio host on public broadcast uh fm
radio
and then uh xm right or was it seriously
serious
one of them was serious they're now
they're now the same uh
took you know hired him away into this
walled off pay per prescription and i
think that
they were pretty pleased that they did
that he made a ton of money he was
uncensored in a way that he was
couldn't have been on the public radio
broadcast radio rather
and what did it do for his career did
did it made him wealthy but did it make
him
have wider reach more narrow reach no
but you know it's uh
it's i for me i'd call her retirement is
he still even doing it
he is he is and he's super anti-trump
and he's super pro establishment he's
apologized for being
you know off color and stuff he's really
just become this you know vanilla yogurt
boring you know i don't listen to his
show to be honest but i was reading
back in the day back back oh yeah he's
apologized for a ton of things he's
denied
saying some of the things he said in the
past he was a shock jock he was the
shock jock
i look at it this way man if if somebody
takes a massive payout to do that big
jump
for me in my personal opinion and i mean
no disrespect to howard stern or joe i
look at it like you're
it's a retirement it's like you do this
hard work you do it for a long time
you reach the top of the mountain what
do you do someone comes along and says
we're going to cash out your chips 100
million bucks yeah okay
yeah i'm done man i'm i beat the casino
i'm ready to go
yeah now i can hang out but to be fair
though like joe got the best pop like
one of the best deals in the world he's
getting uh
wall street journal report i don't i
don't i'm assuming that their their data
you know their facts are straight they
said 100 million bucks
and now he hasn't got to worry about
getting banned dude wow
is that really accurate i mean i suppose
the contract is so big that they're not
going to cancel him due to internal
pressure
i kind of feel like i wonder if in his
contract it says
if they sever he gets the payout because
then it's kind of like ban me
do it right right then i'm free and i
get the money
he'd be pushing that for sure uh it's
just an interesting
thing to think about sort of setting up
a walled garden around your content and
what is the goal of what you're doing
i mean remember i remember listening to
the joe brogan podcast
back when there was just it was just
this tripped out weird intro
and they were just talking about mma and
his comedian friends yeah and and that
was it
do you know the story the dragon tim
pool story i mean which one
the the original like how it all went
down no
this is a great story so uh during
occupy wall street
like a couple like a month after
occupying a drinking game with occupy
wall street
so after after uh it was like a month
after they shut down the park
so it still existed joe's podcast was on
ustream i think he was getting like
decent viewership
but uh it was just like the joker
experience on ustream it was you know
and so people were tweeting at him you
got to have tim pool on your show
and so he tweeted at me something like
yeah man i'm down let's make it happen
we dm'd and then i was like super
excited
and so i wasn't trying to push it
because i was i think i was 25 and i'm
like
this is going to be awesome joe rogan is
famous comedian so i bought a plane
ticket
and i said okay he's booked me he's told
me where to be
he's told me the time i got in the plane
i fly to la
as soon as i land my phone goes sorry
dude i can't do it i got something come
up and i was like
you know what man nobody i can't get mad
at somebody for not doing me a favor
but i was smart about it i said there's
an event a protest happening in la so
i definitely have something i can do
while i'm here and i can hang out with
people so it was a bummer
now like a year goes by and people are
tweeting at joe again like dude
you gotta get on temple now it's 2012
and he he tweets at me and he's like
uh he's like you know we tried doing it
last year and it didn't work out
what do you say man and i was like yeah
let's do it man for sure and he's like
all right let's do it
so uh again tells me time tells me the
place i get on the plane
no i land sorry dude can't do it
and then he had he still had a show he
just bumped me for other people
he he bummed me for other people what a
dick
and so uh he double he doubles
booked you you flew across well it was
the first time then a year later
and dick move this was this was back it
was less formal and
uh i was at a point in my career where i
was like i have to take that risk
totally you know it's like if if he
bumps me
it's i i can't sit here and be like
cover my costs do this i was like no i'm
at that point like i'm not
i think i had like 13 000 twitter
followers but i had enough people
following my live on the ground
reporting that you know got his
attention
and so that was it i i was i was pissed
and i damned almost like bro how are you
doing this like
are you kidding me dude like this is the
second time i flew out here and then
he just didn't respond and i was like
whatever man i'm over it
i'm over it and so that was that was it
for a couple years
and then i guess uh he he he just one
day hit me up and was like bro i'm so
sorry about how that went down
he's like i guess he was saying like he
didn't really like he didn't really he
didn't realize
because for him it was like he does his
show and doesn't matter like he didn't
he didn't realize i'm some dude like
trying to come out all excited and so he
apologized and asked me to come he's
like if you ever want to come to one of
my shows man just let me know
and so uh we went because i was in
philly and i was like you are you and
phil anytime soon he's like oh dude i'm
in philly like next week
and i was like bro and he was like dude
come on down
went down to his show and then uh
his show was amazing yeah and then he
invited us backstage and hung out and he
was like i'm sorry about that it was
basically just like
like i said you know for him he's this
famous media and he does his thing and
it was kind of nonchalant like he didn't
think it mattered
and for me i'm like this hungry young
greek yeah this hungry young dude like
super excited
and then it wasn't him trying to screw
me over it was just like
it was it was something came up and he
didn't he was like whatever it would
have been like
getting booked for carson and you know
in like the 70s or the 80s johnny carson
and you're like in the green room ready
to go on and they're just like nah yeah
sorry dude but uh you know but he was
like dude i didn't realize you were
flying out for this man
like i feel so bad he's like you know
and then he's apologized but then
if something funny happened um i did a
video about his jack dorsey podcast
yeah that got like major down votes and
uh
i did like a 10 or 13 minute segment or
something
he auto copyright claimed it so i
uh get a notification for a copyright
claim that all my revenue is not going
to go to this company
and so i dm i'm like yo hey man like you
i think
i think was automatic because i showed a
screenshot of the podcast
and then uh he was like oh sorry about
that let me let me take care of it
then he comes back like 50 minutes later
he's like hey man you made some really
good points can i can i call you right
now
and i was like all right sure and so uh
he calls me we talked about uh just like
what i'd said in my segment about
twitter and the censorship and what was
going on
and he was like man man yeah he's like i
you know what man i owe you you got to
come on the show sometime we'll figure
it out we'll figure out i'm like yeah no
problem he's like yeah yeah we'll figure
out
he's like dude i really appreciate this
like you know helping me understand
what's going on twitter and stuff i was
like for sure
so i'm sitting there in my in my shorts
i'm playing world of warcraft and then
my phone rings
and i'm like it was joe rogan and i'm
like hello
and then he goes do you want to come on
the show on friday and it was wednesday
and i was like
i gotta i got like this friday i gotta
fly tomorrow i was like yeah i was like
all right like i guess so and then
from there it just kind of fell into
place the twitter thing with jack dorsey
which i gotta so basically
after we did that show he was like we
gotta do something crazy and don't tell
anybody
we're gonna try and see if we can pull
it off i don't know if it'll happen
don't don't cite you know if we talk
about it
it you know people probably it'll jinx
it so we'll just see if it happens
and then you get a call come out we're
gonna do this thing and i was like
it's like i'm gonna sit in front of ceo
of twitter and their lawyer and i was
like whatever
man dude you were on point i watched
that one you were on point
i didn't prepare like i didn't i didn't
do anything like extra
yeah yeah like i didn't sit down and say
like okay here's what i talk about i was
just like yeah tell me where to sit
you knew all the stuff already it's all
in your head you know
after the fact i was like oh there's a
couple things i could have done better
but
whatever i'm not i wasn't there for
anybody but you know i wasn't there for
for other people i was there because
there was a lot of things i was angry
about a lot of things i had seen that i
wanted to talk about
so it didn't wasn't an issue but i do
think they thought it was going to be
why did you ban alex jones and they're
going to like because he said this
and i would go fine no it was like those
deeper philosophical questions about
what does it mean to break the rules
what's the political like perspective
perception on your rules and like who
who made you the arbiter of what what's
acceptable politics and stuff like that
yeah and it was clear
too that they seem to be learning things
from you at that time and they don't
know exactly what's all going on inside
of there
nothing's changed nothing's changed i
have i have similar story about getting
bumped to several times dave rubin has
asked me
he's come on his show three times now i
did not fly
out luckily but it's always like all
right let's do let's do let's do it and
then
something happens let's do it let's do
it and it's something and it's fine
that's how it works the game works i did
i did i did a live stream
in like 2016 i think because people had
asked me about what had happened with
joe rogan and so i did a stream
explaining what happened then i just
said listen man i'm not mad at anybody
because
i can't get mad at someone for not doing
me a favor right like him offering me up
this show
i was like flying out to la the second
time and getting bumped
is mildly perturbing i was mildly
perturbed to put it uh
put it that way yeah but but at the same
time it's like
i i took the risk i took the shot it
didn't happen i'm not gonna be mad at
anybody you know i'm not gonna hold the
grudge or anything like that
how do you handle something like that
tim what did you do what'd you do when
you get the call
when you get the text i just landed six
hour flight i damned him back
like yo what wtf and then i moved on
with my life
i was like perfect i was like yeah what
do you what
the problem was like i knew who he
bumped me for who was it i'm not going
to say their name it was multiple people
but i guess he i guess like for him it
was like
business yeah i got these people i can
get them on right now i better do it i
got to tell him i can't do it yeah
and then he didn't know that i flew out
i got it so i you know he probably
didn't realize fair enough
i mean i thought it was a dick move but
you know i don't hold it against them
it's just and this was eight years ago
this was
like his show was not that big it was
just like ustream it was like
you know one of the first like podcasts
it sir was i didn't even realize i'm
like
why am i listening to this it worked out
for me
because then he ends up being like i
feel really bad about how that all went
down man you should come out to my show
and then come on the show and like we
ended up doing uh one of the most
significant shows he had like to sit
down with these absolutely and
what's interesting to think about is if
he had had you on earlier
it would have been less impactful right
then right going on
later when his audience had grown and
his reach had grown
such a dramatic effect so it all worked
out in the end tim
and now you're talking and then uh
skateboarding yeah well so
the the the last time i went on earlier
this year it was because
i probably shouldn't there was there was
somebody else who wanted to do a
political discussion
left right like you know me him and joe
rogan and i'm like you're still just
like
one of the problems with these
conversations on joe's show is often
it's liberals and leftists
talking about conservatives without
bringing conservative on
he's had on crowder before i think too
but like
the the twitter thing was you know
rogan's
pretty left and then i'm like left
leaning but you know
very critical of critical race theory
and uh you know like a disaffected
liberal type
but there were no hardcore conservatives
in a conversation about conservative
censorship
so that's that's one of the things too
so uh you know i went on
uh rogan's show earlier this year
because we were supposed to do
like leftist commentator me and
joe and then covet happened so the other
person was like i can't i can't make it
and then out and and so i was like i'll
i'll come whatever i'll take the van i
got this van i need to drive it you know
we'll go drive it and then we've had the
white van
i had a guy join the liminal order and i
interviewed him
just the other day who told me that he
first started listening to joe rogan
then he heard about you and then he saw
me on your show
so so the joe rogan radicalization
funnel
is in full effect starts with joe passes
through tim
ends up with me radicalized doing all
kinds of man
stuff man stuff it's just amazing the
way that the network works and how you
put out content and people come to you
and and how this whole web is just being
woven all over
the country and you're at the forefront
man you're pushing things you're pushing
huge numbers
and competing with the big guys i mean
we got it we got it we gotta we gotta
simmer down on politics a lot
yeah we have to we have to so uh
i can't announce anything specific but
i'll just say and you know the details
so don't say anything
we're planning a really big show which
is
it's not going to be political but it's
with someone very political it's going
to get me in trouble
it's going to be but but yeah so well
you know that's that's in a couple of
weeks
it's just i'm just asking for trouble
doing what i do
indeed well you got to have fun i think
you said to me once just to not be bored
yeah so so the idea is we're having on
some pretty prominent
political uh figures but we're not going
to talk politics
good because one of the things we're
talking about it's like okay this is
going to be
risky youtube's like you know trigger
trigger happy
if we if we bring on some controversial
figures but i'm like or so it was
proposed to me like we should talk about
all these other things
outside of you know basically once the
media shifted to the trump narrative
it's been trump talk politics all all
day nonstop and there are other cultural
issues
yes that kind of got brushed aside in
the past
you know 10 months or whatever five
years even
i am booking a whole new slot of guests
for my podcast jack murphy live on
youtube
uh and i'm deliberately trying to stay
away from politics history culture
science futurism actors
uh comedians like really trying to go
with evergreen content
back to things that can really help
people in their lives rather than just
swinging for the fences with the you
know brawling in the political sphere
we're all kind of exhausted by that yeah
yep yeah the election's over
so uh tomorrow i'm going i did one
segment this morning
and then i was like and take the rest of
the day and then but we're gonna do the
show late at night and then
uh tomorrow's thanksgiving you know i'm
gonna have some
turkey or something i have no idea
whatever but we should do some we should
we should have super chats because we
went a little longer hello super chats
if you have not already smash the like
button give a little tap there's a
little there's a little thumbs up it
really does help
and uh thank you for doing so and don't
forget to subscribe
hit the uh uh smash like button
subscribe notification bell
let's read from uh some of these super
chats
colin p says people often need a common
enemy to unite against to bring them
together
i suggest uh us ps5 owners gang up on
tim for not having a ps5
haha ups for trash yes um i will have a
ps5 in a couple days when it comes in
the mail ps4 more like ps4
ps5 all i play is skater xl and spelunky
anyway
it's pretty straightforward but it's
because i beat dragon dragon quest a
long time ago and you know i beat skyrim
50 million times
and then fallout wasn't fallout 76
wasn't that good so
i used to play destiny all the time and
uh the division
played the divide you played victims at
all uh no when i was younger i
pioneered the atari 2600 and
colecovision and all that
you might like division i don't know
where they're at now division two
but it's basically there's a pandemic
causes you know basically
complete collapse and then but the cool
thing about it is that
you're getting away from politics well
but it's it's a game where it's like a
tom clancy game you play as a special
operative
uh the president and acts presidential
director 51 creating you know
a remnants of the government trying to
hold things together and you're in new
york
the first one is new york city the
second one i think this went back to new
york city but what's cool is like
the guns are real guns like you actually
find guns and you do mods and i'm pretty
sure for the most part they're based on
all real guns
so it's like yeah it seems like you know
a game conservers are probably gonna get
a kick out of i mean probably a lot of
clancy games they'd probably like
charles w says holy cow twitter just
suspended the republican who chairs the
committee that held the hearing on pa's
election today
unbelievable we were talking about that
earlier yep
let's see the hylian gigolo says five
years been a mental health nightmare
fran had psych break from it he thinks
he lives in 96.01 down to the tech he uh
down to the tech he has
talks only about events like bill's
scandals stares into space if i bring up
any event since 9 11 wow
crazy scott bullion says covid will
never go away because democrats know how
to steal elections now
garrett crowl says 72 of republicans
will leave the gop if a trump party is
formed
trump needs to do this and pick his
legislature turn the gop into a second
party
i mean that might result in a
conservative split which gives democrats
a super majority for
a long time bill clinton got elected
yeah 40 something percent of the vote
barely wow
well that that that was also ross perot
that's i mean yeah it was through
three parties and and clinton didn't
even win uh
a majority or even come close jewelry
m144 says found you through jeremy from
the quartering been stuck ever since we
just had him on uh a couple days ago
yeah jeremy school did we had him
you know i've known jeremy for a bit
he's cool gone fall says about the biden
laptop i saw a post about how the
computer repairman closing shop and is
appearing
amid purported death threats your
thoughts i did not hear that it's what
we talked about earlier man
the uh uh it's the tactics that leftists
use
you you like so you have this judge
issuing the injunction on the pa
certification
and i'm saying like i think you know ian
miles strong tweeted that judge is
probably getting inundated with death
threats right now right remember the
judge
who like the dude showed up to her house
and shot her son yes
shot her son and then like shot shot her
husband and then took off or whatever
dress like a fedex guy man it's like the
movies
crazy stuff worse demonic sensation says
hey
tim jack and lids love the stream if
trump somehow wins any thoughts on him
standing down
and pence taking over to calm the
leftist storm not sure if it's possible
but an interesting thought
hey from australia by the way i don't i
don't think that would calm anybody
pence would not calm the left at all
yeah he's he like
he's far more conservative right the
joke he's yeah way more conserving the
joke was like if you impeach trump
and convict him you're gonna get penced
like have you thought about that one
thing ahead let's see jarhead steve says
if this continues the bell ringers are
going to have to do what we know to do
semper fi trent lamalino says we need to
we need to lead a movement to stop
giving money companies that are crooked
to companies that are crooked
list of companies that are anti-america
and lead a huge exodus boycott with
money not tweets yep
yeah absolutely let's see
john doe says greetings as a muslim i'm
really happy to see 17 to 30 percent of
us voted trump
but i think trump should have courted us
with his mideast peace policy we heavily
voted based on foreign policy and i wish
we would wake up happy thanksgiving wow
that's interesting yeah the foreign
policy was big for me too
yeah it's a high number of muslims and
we know uh the good news the good news
now for
the uh neocons and the the warmongers is
that uh with joe biden in place rest
assured
they'll be bombing kids in no time but
we'll be nice about it yeah but he'll be
hoping
he'll somehow he'll smile and wink at
you and say come on man and he'll go
i can't be mad at you joe grandpa joe
can i play with your leg hairs
i know right ginger prime says hey tim
i'm another fence sitter and love the
content and honestly
that being said i listen to will of the
people every day and want to know when
we can get a video and professional
version of words in a book
that song hits my heart and soul i guess
if uh at a certain point if i
so so right now my main channel my first
channel i ever put together was
youtube.comcast i do one segment
but it's the other channel where i do
five if i
wind that down to just one in the
morning and then one at four i'll have
tons of time to
i could record a whole album in a week
because then like nishra uh uh
is the one who produced the song and did
all the arrangement and everything so
dude i've got like a thousand do it i
got some really simple poppy ones that
people seem to like they're really just
simple pop rock maybe like indie-ish
nine-tailed fox 1000 says tim i am
totally convinced the dems stole the
election
and if trump told the american people to
take up arms in his name i would happily
do so
that is a very similar comment that
reuters published and i think it freaks
me out
i don't like i don't like the idea but
uh i don't know what to say about it
like what do you do
yeah i i i have no idea that sentiment
won't go away
it won't go away i don't think trump is
going to ask anybody to do that i'm
pretty sure
he's going to fight it as far as he can
in the courts and then that'll be that
shadow government come on
i mean something something's going to
happen it's not it's not going to be
normal
just that's the easiest way to put it
whatever happens we are not going back
to the normal way things used to be
there's no such thing
it's not going to happen joe radler says
tim
sell copies of those paintings of
youtubers you have on your studio walls
of youtubers uh can you put switch to
ian's camera
even though he's not here so the art you
see on the screen
is from g prime85 on twitter instagram
it's george alex opolis we had him on
the show last week
but uh it's none of youtubers it's just
creepy
creepy art it's really good there's joe
biden eating a small
child and he has a bunch of them and uh
you can check him out at
g prime85 on instagram to see all the
other art he has but i think
i don't i don't know if he sells them
but i i hit him up and said dude we got
to get
you know full frame of these comics
because they're amazing comics
we have one with uh trump joe rogan and
joe biden
captain spence says we need to start
protesting outside police departments
asking them not to enforce lockdowns
we must protect our liberty and rights
to assemble well protest as you see fit
i think the most powerful protest
nonviolent civil disobedience is to just
go about your life go about your life
living well is the best revenge
but it's like just go have see your
family be safe
you know but uh i can't believe they're
like don't go to christmas and don't go
to thanksgiving it's like
i think people love their families more
than they're worried about getting sick
yeah you know and and i think the bigger
issue is that when gavin newsom and
other democrats
flaunt the rule like just disobey their
own rules nobody believes it's serious
and it's their fault
they extinguished all credibility with
their corona posture
when they uh accepted and encouraged the
protests and the riots this summer
and this public health officials came
out and said racism is more of a public
health
issue than corona get out there and
protest
everybody that was the end of trust
period if the financial crisis wasn't
bad enough in 2009
when nobody took got any penalties for
the fleecing of the american economy and
the stripping of the treasury
then this is the final straw this this
disconnect between
public statement and policy and then the
private behavior
of the officials who are supposed to
enact it and then and then just a public
health official saying
racism is more important issue think
about it this way the left clearly
already doesn't believe there's a rule
of law
they say we're locked down don't do
these things they go and do it anyway
they go right and they go protest
yeah so the fact that they're rioting
shows they don't care they don't care
then for the right
they're being told we're going to
destroy your businesses your livelihoods
it's where
take away your jobs and you can clearly
see there's no rule of law because the
left is smashing everything up
that's amazing to me it's almost like
we're in you know i wonder if we're in a
simulation and doing an experiment to
see at what point conservatives just
like
lean back and then like and just go back
to work
it's here's what's amazing you you
actually have people rioting
being cut loose the da's let them go and
then conservatives can watch that happen
and be like but i'm not going to sell my
t-shirts at my clothing store
it's like the the levels of willingness
to break the law on the left are just
like
off the charts and conservatives are all
the way at the bottom okay but
it's important to remember that those
antifa activists and protesters and
rioters that deliberately go out and put
them
they know their coach that they can get
arrested and that they have a defense
fund and they have people that are
getting them out on bail
there's a system that so it's not
necessarily about like
how bold are we it's is there an
ecosystem
with appointed judges and da's and the
whole thing where they
they know that they're going to be okay
sure but that imagine if the the scale
was
they would sell donuts in a donut shop
versus a conservative selling they don't
send a donut shop that's when you're
equal
yeah and them being like i know i can
get away with it you'd be like well
they're just selling donuts no they've
stepped it up too
they've turned the knob up to 11. yeah
so they know they can get away with not
just
breaking covet lockdown but literally
burning down buildings
okay they can't really get away with
that they are getting charged and
arrested for that but they can be part
they can partake in these riots
and likely will get away with it and
then on the right they're like i know
that if i open my store
they will throw the book at me and
there's something i can do about it yeah
unless there was enough of us
if we had like a day what is the
opposite of a strike
that's what we need we need the opposite
of
i have come up with a brilliant idea a
national working day
and the opposite of a strike the
anti-strike an anti-strike
yeah everybody go to work yeah go to
restaurants go to work go to the gym go
see your family get outside go to church
yeah absolutely go to church just do it
we would overwhelm the system there's no
way they would be able to enforce it
and then we could have that's the point
of another violence obedience yeah
let's do it let's do it the anti-strike
well you gotta
make it happen someone's to organize it
so you know that's what that's what the
right lacks
organizational power the left has it in
spades tom
me says i might be wrong but trump is
treading water biden will get wrecked if
he eventually or actually wins
what do you mean by that like trump is
just treading water like he's not trying
hard enough
like he could do more or he's struggling
to stay afloat
maybe he's saying that he thinks trump
is just biding his time because he knows
he's going to be victorious
sorry yeah i want one i don't either
but there there is a belief that trump
uh i've said this before it seems like
trump's buying time
like a lot of these lawsuits seem
aimless like he's just buying time for
some reason
no idea uh it could be that they're just
trying to
slow things down and slowly wind things
down so that his supporters
calm down and then get past it if they
announced like the election
boom one day and then trump conceded
people would be
would go nuts so it's like everything's
winding down really slowly to keep the
temperature down
i tell you this if trump does end up
conceding at some point it's going to be
on like a friday at midnight
he's going to tweet it to tweet
something out then everyone's already in
bed
it's a weekend they wake up on saturday
they don't pay attention to the news and
then it'll be like oh yeah trump
conceded last week they'll be like oh
really
they always do it like that they always
make big announcements that's when rusev
jinsberg died
yeah yeah died yeah but also they
announced joe biden on saturday
saturday uh what saturday afternoon yeah
so it's a weekend people aren't paying
attention to the news and then they're
like oh here it is we announce it
oh yeah so you know let's see
joshua cherkinski says if you want to
know more about operation warp speed you
should reach out to jose arrieta
former cio of hhs and led data team on
covet task force
he's absolutely brilliant and he has
been asked by several news outlets for
interviews
cool cool spork witch says it's not a
conspiracy the left
is promoting pito's big story with asda
having to take down material promoting
love knows no age limit and other pro
you know
pedo propaganda that is not an isolated
incident it is found throughout social
justice
like i mentioned i think it was i think
it was snapchat it could be wrong you
know
don't sue me snapchat but there was a
filter it had love knows no age
and that's weird very weird
matt morgan says combat vet here after
seeing afghanistan i hope we can avoid
armed conflict
but not at the expense of our rights and
constitution thank you
slash lydia for giving us politically
homeless a voice much love
yeah joel stein says biden at all are
being super smug about everything
you think behind closed doors they're a
bit worried about the situation probably
some clenched sphincters hoping trump
concedes
ernesto jimenez says did tim not do his
afternoon shows it is correct i did not
do them and i won't be doing them
tomorrow either
uh and then we're gonna sort through uh
you know how things are gonna flow in
the future because we got this new skate
park built
and uh definitely want to have events we
have a bunch of stuff ready for
cultural stuff i'll put it this way you
know what's not
what i think is not necessarily helping
sitting down and saying like did you see
this thing today how dumb was that
because at a certain point people were
like i feel this way i'm like how many
times have i said oh they're riding
again and getting away with it
instead of doing something that makes a
difference so i'm not i'm not
a protest organizer but we're going to
put on events yeah and we're going to
help build culture
generate culture art so you know one of
the biggest problems
the modern the new right has terrible
art
but the right is always a terrible art
here's the greatest advantage
conservatives have right now
we have a uh a general agreement on
fundamental principles
in freedom of speech and individual
liberty and you know the foundation of
this country the constitution
cetera so even though i am life leaning
independent
left on on a lot of economic policy
issues and
uh pro-choice and stuff like that i
agree
more on a ton of issues that are
fundamental to the existence of this
country with conservatives
and now people like me and other artists
are now finding themselves being
you know on the right or being told they
are even if they don't agree with the
right on every on
on every issue and now the right is
starting to get
cultural victories so trump was a
cultural victory it was the memoir
all those memes and jokes and internet
culture really helped propel him to
victory yeah
now you're gonna find you know i did
that music video it's really funny
because there are a lot of people who
hate me who are like
this is actually good some people are
saying like man i hate this guy but he
kind of pulled it off
a lot of haters saying i expect it to be
like super cringe but it's actually kind
of good
a great agreed people like it it's
interesting that you're talking about
doing stuff with the culture right now
because part of the reason i think that
daily wire moved to nashville was
because they wanted to expand into the
culture
and people like andrew clavin who write
novels like sean parnell who write
novels
they're a big part of the culture war
too i think that's significant hopefully
we get better movies too you wanna know
something crazy
there's a pro skater who got asked to
promote a brand
and the brand did something critical
race theory-ish
and all of the comments from this
person's followers were trump 2020 maga
and this dude he's like early 20 pro
skater was super confused like
what's going on like i'm getting flooded
with all this manga stuff and then
the brand asked me to take it down
excuse me and he was like i got
no idea man i was so super confused so
some one of the older guys in the
industry who was a trump supporter
skateboarder pro skater grows up and now
he's like this is why you know trump
had to explain to him what was going on
so
i just think you've got a lot of people
who follow skateboarding
there's there's a couple's people i
follow on skateboarding have decent
followings
and they're hardcore maga skateboarders
they're fearless
but it's because they've already been
canceled for some reason or another they
had like
you know their their sponsorships ended
or something so they're just like i'm
just gonna say it
but i'll tell you this man like
there was there's a guy named brandon
turner and he's one of the he's he's a
legend he's a legend in skateboarding
when he was i think he was 18 he did a
trick called a
switch hard flip down something called
the carl's bad gap
basically means he jumped over this
really big thing
it's like jumping down a flight of
stairs doing an extremely hard trick
and it was a big deal when he did it the
dude's 38 right now
and did one of the most mind-blowing
tricks again a switch hard flip that's
what it's called and he did it down
something
a massive set of uh these huge four
stairs
but they're like it's ridiculously big
they're super long it's not really
stairs
it's called the wallenberg gap and the
dude's almost 40.
so anyway i forgot where i was going
with it i had to bring it up though
because it's like
i forgot my point my point was typically
that
you don't have high profile individuals
you don't have
uh people who are making content that
goes viral
in cultural like issues like with
popular music
and uh with skateboarding who are coming
out and being straight up pro-trump
right right well we're looking at
creating uh
children's cartoons actually like one to
three minute cartoons
didn't lauren southern make a children's
book i have no idea
i think she did did she maybe i'm
thinking of somebody else you're
hallucinating
we're looking at that we're looking at
other ways to influence culture like
that
to spread spread the values out there in
the world today for sure
yeah and tim you know you're talking
about getting out of politics and focus
on making change and adding to culture
and being
doing something fun and interesting that
that's what i decided to do two years
ago
and i spend most of my time engaged with
the guys in the liminal order
and just doing our programming there and
actually being a force for good and
actually being a force for positive
change rather than
just droning on no offense to me or to
you or to any of us about politics all
day long you said it best you're like
how many more times can you i say hey
the democrats did this and it's wrong
stupid i know so at a certain point it's
like i'm gonna i'm gonna keep doing it
but
we're gonna make space to be like we're
going to be hanging out
someone's going to roll up and i'm going
to be like dude if you want this new set
of wheels i got to see
i got to see some flip and flip out man
i want to see nollie flip backside tail
slide
i'll tell you what i'll throw in some
bone swiss if your big spin out
most people probably have no idea your
mom's a big spin out i have no idea what
tim just said
but the point is imagine they do that
and we got a gadsden flag on the wall
right there there's a really good
skateboarder named cody mcintyre he's
one of the craziest tracers i've ever
seen on a mini ramp
you're not going to understand any word
a lot of you might understand this if
you skate
this dude i watch this video on
instagram he does
a forward flip blunt kick flip out
i i but he's got don't tread on me on
his mini ramp
that's like uh product placement for
conservative ideas
not even just freedom i know it's right
it's like wow the the don't tread on me
flag is like
the real anti-fascist statement right
yup the og
what about what about this one join or
die
that's the opposite uh lauren lauren
southern did write a children's book
henry the sheepdog and the wolf of
mossville
there is a good there is a good
children's book out there uh let me
remember the name my red hat
look that up my red hat was written by a
maga
uh aware a gentleman for
young children uh to learn the the the
stories of bullying and
and discrimination etc my red hat you
know it's a really good
example of why this needs to happen
because
uh casey neistat i think he's a cool
dude i've known him for for quite a bit
um i think he's all right but he
endorsed hillary clinton and i think
he didn't know anything about hillary
clinton and he actually said he knew the
trump family that they were very nice
but he made a video endorsing hillary
clinton and later on came to regret it
most people who are producing cultural
content vlogs skateboarding don't know
anything about what's going on in the
world and so
somebody comes along and says we're a
super pac we'll pay you x amount of
dollars to promote our candidate they go
oh that sounds good to me
yeah and they don't know anything about
it but i tell you what you come to me
and say michael bloomberg wants to run
he's going to pay you a million bucks to
do a video form and be like
never going to happen i'll tell you what
you give me no stipulations as to what
the video is about i'll make a video
about michael bloomberg
and then i'll make an hour-long
documentary about how awful he is
you know but they wouldn't do it they're
like no no promote him endorsement it's
never gonna happen
that being said i do videos on youtube
and then his videos get placed on my
videos by youtube
but that's great that's great i do a
video saying here's why michael
bloomberg is awful
and then it's like the video that pops
up the advertisement i get paid is him
being like i'm michael bloomberg vote
for me
and then it's like the video stops
here's why michael bloomberg is awful
that's awesome so it's like you're
getting
you're getting you know corrected so
anyway here's why michael bloomberg
sucks
yes he's paying you to say it exactly
just like that whole countdown
thing that just played out did you see
that no which one uh
account dankula was uh being sued for
libel or defamation
you mean you mean sargon oh sargon was a
sargon sargon got sued for a copyright
infringement oh
no no there was just a libel case that
was just settled
and uh she this some chick sued him was
going ape about it
uh they they just kept going the judge
kept saying don't do it they finally got
i think you're talking about sargon am i
did i get this confused
yes yeah oh okay yeah so uh sargon of
akkad
well let me start over because it starts
with aquila akilah filmed what was going
on
on election night in 2016. and so then
sargon took
segments of her full video and then
titled it
sjw levels of awareness she
then tried getting it taken down for
copyright youtube did
sargon challenged it saying it's it's
fair use
it's commentary a bunch of people told
sargon he was wrong they said dude you
just uploaded straight clips you didn't
comment on it at all you just showed the
clips
sargon was really smart he did said
nothing
he said don't worry about it and so when
she finally sued to get taken down
he knew what he was talking about the
title of the video
was commentary and criticism you can
show someone's video
raw as it is on their channel and then
put the title
and it is fair use by showing her video
and titling at sjw's level
sjw levels of awareness it was apparent
to everybody the judge
even akilah's own lawyers who for some
reason
she she changed lawyers i can only
imagine it's because they knew
you're going to lose but they even said
in their like one of their initial
filings
that the only reason he uploaded the
video was to make fun of or like
disparage
and so the judge was like you
acknowledged this was criticism
like that's quintessential fair use she
decided to go forward anyway
and what they think it was uh what is it
called ad terrorim i think
it is i think so it's when you sue
someone knowing that they can't fight
back so they're going to cave and give
you whatever you want
to terror yeah yeah and so that's what
someone had
referred to it as but sargon raised
money defended himself because he knew
he was going to win
and she sent him an email i could be
wrong about this but i believe she sent
an email saying like they wanted to
settle for 40 grand
and so he just was like no thank you he
just won
uh he just won uh uh he didn't just win
but he won
his court fees not only did he win the
case it is fair use
he then sued for court fees to be paid
back
because she was on twitter gloating that
she was trying to take him for all his
worth and like
attack his kids bankrupt him and stuff
and mocking his family and so i guess
the judge said this is not a good faith
copyright suit
this was meant to drum up you know
celebrity or something like that i think
that's what happened
and then she just recently paid him out
yeah but she raised all the money on
gofundme exactly
and and i'll say this my understanding
of what she wrote
she like it was it was it was libelous
it was like intense
lying about the judge but
you know what man the right doesn't
start the fights
the proud boys don't go outside the
fights the pro the proud boys will go to
a rally and when antifa shows up the
fight starts
in that context the proud boys might
start a fight
i'm like i don't know you know at
sargon's business but
she wrote this gofundme raising money
with lies and that's fraud
yeah that this seemed to have been
resolved at least the legal fees
resolved recently by her doing a
gofundme which means her fans are paying
sargon and i just read about that today
which is what i
meant when you brought up sargon earlier
i was like oh yeah that thing that just
happened in the news
so you threw me for a loop there but
we're on point now
we got too many super chats coming in
i'm trying to blaze them
yeah trying to reason as we can ben
jordan says love will of the people tim
can't stop listening to it
if you haven't check out will of the
people you can just search tim cast will
of the people and you can listen if you
haven't
and uh share it because i mean that's
like i'm not i'm i'm gonna do
maybe a marketing thing to boost the
song just because i can and i think it'd
be fun
uh why not but uh it's it's it's going
through the process to go up on spotify
and and other
like you know amazon stuff so that'll
happen at some point but uh you can
check it out and you know what we'll do
at the end of the show we'll just
we'll play it for y'all so you can you
can watch it here and then you know
check it out later
let's see uh doo doo doo waffle sensei
says the tim cast irl
should naturally fill some of the void
left from the joe rogan experience
mankind mankind needs shows like these
thank you for your voluntary service to
talking about your feelings on the
internet and happy thanksgiving
well uh happy thanksgiving to you too
sir yeah for sure uh
joe's not going anywhere he's doing a
show it's on spotify so just you can
watch the videos
yeah so i think there's going to be he's
still doing clips they're still going to
be on youtube so you're all
you're still going to see his content
but you know whatever
matthew spriggs says alex jones bless ch
jank
we would break the internet yeah it
wouldn't work but you know the thing is
jenk wouldn't do it
that's the problem it's like if we got
a high profile leftist and alex jones
it would be one of the biggest political
podcasts ever
the leftists just never want to do it i
asked i think five
i think five leftists to come on with
alex jones they all said no
they know all about well i'm sorry a
couple just ignored me outright
and then you know whatever after the
fact issued a comment saying kovid i
can't do it
let's see ryu kirito says apparently
andrew jackson made his own party when
the presidency was allegedly stolen from
him
and they voted democrat for the next 100
years the jacksonian democrats i think
trump may do the same
i don't see how i think trump took over
the gop and i don't see how
republicans move on they like they can't
just
people are gonna be are pissed they're
saying don't vote republican because
they
the gop abandoned trump
jimmy rustler says tim have you caught
wind of the black rifle coffee s
show true color is being revealed do you
see this with black rifle it has
something to do with kyle rittenhouse in
support of him or not
yes well so they i kind of feel like you
just break a pen
i did there's no i kind of feel like
black rifles
too scared to say they support kyle
reynolds yeah really
so yeah i disagree what do you why what
do you mean
i don't think it's good policy i'm gonna
say my piece this is my hill to die on
okay i don't think it's good policy for
any company to give any form of support
for anyone like kyle rittenhouse whether
you like him or not
and i'm going to get crucified for this
and by like you mean someone who is on
trial for
exactly someone who's on trial someone
who's yeah i understand that
someone who's a hot potato why would you
say they said they don't want to be seen
as profiting off of
that whole situation that's fair i
respect it 100 but i think
what's happening is people expect them
to say of course we support him he was
defending himself
right and i don't i don't feel like we
don't want to say that it's gonna you
know it's gonna be bad for us
adjust your expectations yeah it's going
to look like they're trying to make
money off of it
that's what that's that's that's
basically what happened the media put up
some fake news or whatever
fake news logan matthews says tom clancy
should sue the pandemic for plagiarism
division and division two are like a
prophetic vision of 2020
and the fallout after also plagiarism is
a funny-looking word just notice that
while you were typing it out it happens
to us
words are cool the the game's not uh
identical utopia
is the creepy show because they filmed
that pre-coven
utopia was filmed before covet happened
and it is a show about a wealthy sjw
who fakes a pandemic so that the fda
forces through a vaccine
at the last minute at the demand of the
people and then it sterilizes it i want
to read the book or see the british
the original british version is creepy
and weird it has great music and great
cinematography i heard it's better
so at the end of this jw one is there
one
uh class of people that is you know
spared from the
the the the disease that uh comes
through the vaccine that sterilizes food
because in the original one the guy
plans to erase everybody except his
particular genetic
well we only watch the first season and
that wasn't mentioned yet well so
the british one has two seasons yeah and
the the the the us one has the one
season right now that
came out so good watch the british one i
gotta say i didn't i'm not a fan of the
uh
um it's interesting to watch because of
the parallels but it's
kind of not a good show i really like i
imagine that it sounds stupid
yeah the other one is right up your
alley dude graphic
artists and novels graphic novels and
like hidden messages and like
you know secret internet chat room yeah
yeah that that was in this
this newer version as well i kind of
like that i like some of the types of
secret internet
here's here's here's the here's the
perfect super chat d steve says yo tim
dawg love and appreciate your work man
thank you for what you do
and who's the dude in the beard i want
to follow him he seems pretty metal
lit my name is jack jack murphy
you can find me at jack murphy live on
twitter and on youtube go there
subscribe
let's get me to 30 000. we're almost
there oh sweet almost there jack murphy
live on youtube check it out man on
twitter right and twitter jack murphy
live fairy metal indeed
live everywhere are you on parlor
there's a long story with me
we'll get into it another day uh
instagram facebook everywhere at jack
murphy live i planned it that way
it worked out it's easy to find me do it
safety off says bro if you follow
through with event slash culture
you jack and team could literally be the
catalyst to save this nation
we all need guidance on how to organize
and be heard as high levels are being
excommunicated from society
oh we're going to have comedy shows here
we're going to film them and the jokes
are going to be
uh going to be offensive comedies
like i was watching family guy the other
day probably the most
racist thing i have seen in a very long
time was their episode
where they where the griffins are like
running from the cops and so they go to
china to go to chinatown
and then it was like the whole episode
was just like making fun of asian people
and i'm like i thought it was funny but
it was like wow it was crazy like
watching the whole episode
like there's there's one part where it's
like you're watching cbs chinatown and
the cbs ice
turns and slants wow
like that's airing on tv right now in
these in these days you know yeah
south park gets a pass on that too you
know shitty walk
um but they they uh south park lost
their their teeth a while ago you think
so
i thought absolutely i thought last
season was pretty good they it seems
like they're trying not to not to push
too hard
like they're they're making fun of pc
principal but they're not making fun of
him enough
like they're not really making fun of
him so it's like
the pc babies it's kind of like what's
the joke i don't know you know like i
guess
yeah i guess you you like they used to
be totally gruesome like the episode
where the kid eats his own parents
scott tenderman yeah scott tannerman
there's a lot of good episodes
yeah south park's got a story history
and great great episodes though
yeah i wonder if at a certain point
there's phoning it in you know i mean
they're not putting out any new
material right now this is the time
where they usually
do i was waiting for their new season
they put out one episode one special
yeah with randy having sex with the bat
in china
with mickey mouse him and mickey mouse
gang banging doing oh can i say that
a little late in the show maybe happy
thanksgiving everybody a little late in
the show
i hope everyone's ready all the kids are
gone can i say that
oh you already did whatever dunsky
so we got anton maxon says before covet
i was an aspiring actor attending the ny
performing arts academy
i'm working on many scripts now when i
write my emotions take over and it
transforms into this weird abstract
thing
may i send you first edits via wix i
like your input yes that is the
appropriate place to send stuff let's
see
brian brown says i have been watching
your other channels for a while
but first time watching a stream love
your content sincerely pdx trump
supporter appreciate it
stay safe out there pdx
doobie mcnasty says jack m f murphy
what's up doobie
vosh 1985 says the division is based off
of operation dark winter look it up
wait wait what i don't know is that
we gotta look it up operation dark
winter sorry my phone yeah they can't
look it up
you're looking joe biden said there was
gonna be a dark winter dark winter he
did indeed
long winter what is operation dark
winter i'm very curious now i'm sorry
alexa my phone died stop we actually
have one you're gonna oh
sorry yeah you're gonna turn around all
right
what is operation operate oh this is
real operation dark winter wait what let
me pull this up
all right we're going to look at this
we're going to learn about this real
fast before we sign off
so the division is about a pandemic
destroying new york and then you go into
to like
fix everything operation dark winter
was the code name for a senior level
bioterror attack simulation conducted on
june 22nd and 23rd 2001 before 911. it
was designed to carry out a mock version
of a covert and widespread smallpox
attack on the us
tara o'toole and thomas inglesby of the
johns hopkins center for civilian
biodefense strategies
center first for strategic and
international studies
and randy larson and mark demir of
analytic services were the principal
designers authors and controllers of the
dark winter project
they say dark winter was focused on
evaluating
the inadequacies of a national emergency
response during the use of a biological
weapon against the american populace
the exercise was intended to establish
preventative measures
and response strategies by increasing
governmental and public awareness of the
magnitude
and potential of such a threat posed by
about biological weapons
and then basically in the game some dude
steals it
some virus releases it and then the
government declares article you know the
president next
directive 51 which gives him total
control and then you come
in to try and uh fix everything but let
me let me let me let me see some more
quick
that would have been a good thing for
trump to do had he been a real fascist
good opportunity didn't do it from
healthline
the u.s is likely headed for a dark
winter
there it is what former vice president
joe biden stated that we likely
we are likely to have a dark winter
with cove at 19. joe what are you doing
he was briefed on that uh that practice
directed i wonder if
i find joe biden like they were like say
something say something crazy that will
make all the conspiracy theorists go
insane
say it's gonna be a dark winter they'll
look it up and they'll be like what's
operation dark winter and then they'll
freak out
there you go man director 51 coming at
ya just kidding who knows yeah
well anyway we went we went a little
over today because i don't know whatever
it was fun it was fun
thanks very much tim my pleasure glad to
be here anytime lids
thank you we are absolutely we are not
having shows uh
uh we have no show tomorrow night it's
thanksgiving hang out with your family
and uh nothing for black friday either
so we'll be back the monday
after this weekend but uh i'm taking
tomorrow off for my show too just to
have a thanksgiving to myself
and then i think i should be back by
friday um i might put something out
tomorrow i just
depends you know because i don't want to
be bored if i'm bored i'm going to be
like are you going to do something
no i'm probably going to just keep
skating and trying to get we're we're
installing new lights and there's a lot
of work that has to go down in the
building the new building so
you know i think culture is going to be
very very important and
having that space where cool things
happen we want to make
we want to make younger people feel
excited and energized
by good ideas and the way you do that is
you create a space where people are
comfortable cool confident
and these kids aspire to be welcomed and
accepted and accomplish these things and
stuff like that so
kind of the goal indeed right on support
though you want to shout out your
channels one more time i would like to
do that thanks for having me jack murphy
live on youtube
jack murphy live on twitter
jackmarphylab.com as well
podcast long form with some interviews
mixed in
follow me i appreciate it thank you very
much for having me guys and you can
follow me on twitter instagram parlor at
timcast my other channels are
youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comtymcastnews of course
if you haven't go to itunes and
subscribe to this podcast there and all
other podcast platforms but uh it does
help when people you know give us good
rating and all the stuff or if you're
listening on the podcast give us a good
rating
and uh greatly appreciate it so we'll be
back on monday
at 8 p.m live so make sure you hang out
with your family and have a good time of
course you can follow
that's our petulance can sour patch
let's lips
and uh i believe ian will be we'll be
back on uh on monday as well so
hopefully so yeah we'll be we'll be back
into the full swing of things but
the holidays are always so rough to work
through because nobody wants to work
like new year's is coming but i wonder
what's going to happen now at this
lockdown what are people going to do for
new year's
no no new year's eve in new york watch
some youtubes
no new york time no uh times square huh
yeah they'll drop the ball and no one
will be there
damn it's like it's like a black mirror
episode it is all right everybody thanks
for hanging out
we will see you all monday at 8 pm live
take care
bye guys
you